So chat, auf geht's!
Wie viele YouTube-Taps sie immer offen haben, ja ich hab schon ein paar Videos offen, die
man uns gleich angucken kann.
Aber nicht alle, vielleicht ein bisschen viel.
Killfilz, zwei Monate, danke für den Sub!
Das ist irgendeine Mario Kirby Sonic, frag mich nicht, Musik-Kompilation.
Hier haben sich ja ein paar Leute beschwert, wie cringe das Intro ist, aber ich wusste
das das Intro ist, ich sag's ja sogar selbst.
Ich bin nicht eingeloggt, das ist geil, ich krieg das Video empfohlen, vielleicht kriegt
noch mehr Leute das Video auf ihrer Startseite empfohlen.
11k Views in ca. 10 Stunden oder so, ist schon okay.
Ich geb zu, ich geb zu, das Intro in dem Video war auch cringe, aber ich hab mir gedacht,
ey, das ist so schlecht, dass es schon wieder gut ist, das muss ich nicht nochmal aufnehmen.
Und morgen ist es soweit, we nice unleashed, mal gucken ob die Leute spielen, ich bin ja
mal echt gespannt.
Da steht und fällt mit, ob's ordentlichen Content gibt.
Ansonsten schauen wir mal, was mich wundert ist, dass irgendwie noch keiner der größeren
Battlefield Channels das Ganze aufgegriffen hat.
Gibt's mal ein altes Intro noch, du meinst das Tätas Intro, was gibt's noch, ja, aber
Intro sind out 2020 auf YouTube, weil die Leute haben mittlerweile so eine kurze Aufmerksamkeit
Spanne, dass wenn du 8 Sekunden Intro machst am Anfang, die Leute gleich ausschalten,
das ist kein Witz.
Das ist ja auch nice, ich mein, ich krieg nicht mehr so viele Views, wie vor dem ganzen
Zeug.
Außerdem dauert es immer eine Weile, bis der Algorithmus wieder das Ganze hier aufpickt,
bis sich die Abos aufgeräumt haben, das ist immer ein bisschen demotivierend, wenn man
nach einer Weile auf YouTube wieder anfängt, weil man kriegt erst mal instant De-Abos bei
jedem Video.
Das liegt aber gar nicht mal so sehr daran, dass die Videos irgendwie viel beschissener
sind als früher, oder anders sind, oder sonst wo, du kannst exakt die gleichen Videos machen,
das kann genauso vielen Leuten gefallen, YouTube räumt irgendwie Abos auf, sobald man
was hochlädt.
Ich verstehe den Sinn davon nicht, aber es ist halt YouTube Logik, das muss man nicht
verstehen, weil das sieht man immer, erst mal instant De-Abos und dann über den restlichen
Tag über gibt's da wieder welche, ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Aber ist nicht schlimm, es dauert immer ein bisschen, bis man im Algorithmus wieder
landet.
Ja.
Und dazu kommt, eins darf man ja auch nicht vergessen, ich muss euch mal kurz was bei
mir auf dem Channel zeigen, ich könnte übrigens, wisst ihr was mir gerade auffällt, ich könnte
mal übelsten Low Effort Content machen auf YouTube und einfach Max reagiert auf sein
erstes Video.
Wobei ihr wisst ja, das ist gar nicht das erste Video, das erste Video gibt's nicht
mehr, weil da Musik drinne war, aber, wobei die ersten zwei Videos gibt's glaub ich nicht
mehr, weil da Musik drinne war, aber das geht auch, das geht auch, das ist ein gutes Thema.
Max ärgert sich Hackerlobby, mit Massive Sound Qualität Leute, okay doch, so schlecht ist
die Audio-Quali doch gar nicht, oder, naja doch die Audio-Quali sackt schon ziemlich.
Live-Reaction im Stream, das ist langweilig, ich glaub nicht, was soll ich da großartig
zu sagen.
Vielleicht nachher, vielleicht nachher, aber das könnt ihr echt mal machen, ich reakte
auf mein erstes Video, hat der Friseur ja auch gemacht, hat er, hat er, hat er, eif,
hat er eigentlich mal wieder was Neues gemacht jetzt, nee, was, warum krieg ich denn bitteschön
jetzt Battlefield 4 Revolution Events angezeigt, YouTube hat sich gedacht, oh ja, sieben Jahre
nach Release, das ist jetzt eine gute Idee, dass ich dir Battlefield 4 Videos zeige, excellent.
Oh, der Senior DevOps ist da jetzt, das ist gut, das geben wir auch nicht zu viel Geld
in der Cloud aus.
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt, das hab ich auch, äh, prä-serif, dass ich teilweise Videos
gar nicht angezeigt bekomme von Channels, die ich abonniert hab und eine Weile nichts
gemacht hab, ja das stimmt, das stimmt, es sackt eigentlich, wenn man überlegt, gerade
Leute, die wieder am Start sind und dann interessiert es mich ja vielleicht erst recht, naja, aber
eins darf man auch auf YouTube nicht vergessen, YouTube ist halt auch übelst competitive Plattform
geworden mittlerweile.
Also es gibt mittlerweile deutlich mehr Content als Leute, die diesen Content überhaupt gucken
können und ich rede jetzt nicht von Random Content, die irgendwelche Leute hochgeladen
haben, weil sie gerade irgendwie der Meinung waren, naja, ich filme jetzt mal, wo ich hier
lang laufe oder so, sondern Content, der potentiell auch so gemacht ist und darauf ausgelegt ist,
dass er geschaut wird, da gibt es viel, viel mehr Content als Leute, die den ganzen Kram
überhaupt gucken können.
Benutzst du jetzt eigentlich das Mikrofon von deinem Headset?
Ja, warum, wie kommst du drauf?
Exe Ich hab mir heute Morgen was überlegt, ich
hab heute Morgen auf dem Tablet ein bisschen umgeguckt und da wurde mir ein Video empfohlen,
ein MW2 Speedrun, die gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an, der ist zu lang, sowas hier in
der Richtung wurde mir empfohlen und ich hab mir gedacht, ich frag den Typ einfach mal,
ob ich mit jemand anderem zusammen seinen Run kommentieren darf bei mir auf YouTube,
weil ich finde den übelst geil anzugucken, der ist halt ein bisschen lang jetzt, eine
halbe Stunde und vielleicht will er ja, also er selbst wird es nicht können, weil ich
glaube nicht, dass er Deutsch spricht, aber ich werde ihn dann ein paar Sachen zufragen,
warum er manche Sachen so macht und dann werden wir uns da mal eine halbe Stunde zu
auslassen.
Ich glaube das ist recht interessant, ich hatte ja auch schon einige Speedrun Videos
bei mir auf dem Channel, das ist jetzt schon ein bisschen her, ich hab ja auch noch ein
bisschen nichts mehr gemacht, mit wem, das weiß ich noch nicht genau, ja das weiß man
nicht so genau, anscheinend, anscheinend, also es gehen ja die Gerüchte um, dass YouTube
letztens zu wenig Speicher hatte, dass sie irgendeine Quota, irgendwelche Quotaprobleme
mit Speicher hatten für ihr Loginsystem, ja kann sein, wir werden es wahrscheinlich
nicht erfahren, was es wirklich war, vielleicht hat auch nur der falsche aus Versehen auf
den falschen Button gedrückt, passiert bei den besten, das ist eigentlich eine gute
Idee, oh Leute ich bin echt müde noch, Putzfrau hat gedrückt, ich glaube die Putzfrau kann
bei Google nicht viel kaputt machen, aber wenn irgendein Techniker oder sonst wie irgendeiner
der halt Zugriff auf irgendwelche Dashboards und sonst was hat auf den falschen Button
gedrückt, kann vielleicht schon mal was passieren, so, gucken wir uns jetzt an, das Cyberbug
20, oh nee da hab ich keinen Bock drauf, das wird ja schon überall breit gedreht ohne
Ende ey, wir können uns das neueste Alpha 4 Games Video angucken, das hab ich noch nicht
gesehen, was Open Worlds 2020 noch von Gothic lernen können, ja es gibt eine Sache, ich
weiß wahrscheinlich haben die meisten Leute das Originale Gothic gar nicht gespielt,
also eine Sache was moderne Spiele wirklich von Gothic lernen können ist, die sollen
in Extremo als Soundtrack reinbauen, weiß nicht hat einer von euch Gothic überhaupt
gespielt, das Originale, da gab es den Auftritt von in Extremo mit halt recht fragwürdigen
Animationen, also die waren halt schlecht für die heutige Zeit, ja, ich weiß wie ging
das, irgendwie geht es nicht mehr zusammen, also, ja genau, genau, Alkenas, ja, ja in
Gothic 1 gab es in Extremo damals, ich glaube in der Remastered gibt es es nicht mehr, weil
sie die Rechte, nicht in der Remastered, was war ich denn, in irgendeiner Gold Edition
oder sowas gibt es es dann glaube ich nicht mehr, weil sie nicht mehr die Rechte hatten
oder sowas, ach keine Ahnung, zumindest, das können sie echt lernen, komm wir das Video
gucken wir uns jetzt mal an, mal gucken was die, mal gucken was die Gamester dazu sagt,
achso und jetzt mal ernsthaft, wenn man mal unabhängig davon gucken würde was Open Worlds
von Gothic lernen können, mal ehrlich, handgecraftete Map, größer automatisch generierte Map, was
bringt mir eine riesen ultra krasse Map, wie in Assassin's Creed Odyssey oder sonst wo,
die eigentlich nur langweilig ist, klar Assassin's Creed haben immer ein paar handgecraftete
Schauplätze, aber das meiste ist dann einfach nur da, damit man irgendwelche Kisten und
Collectibles verstecken kann ohne jeglichen Sinn und Verstand, also handgecraftete Map
eindeutig besser als riesen random generierte Map, was meine ich auch ein bisschen an Breath
of the Wild gesehen hat, die haben eine gute Mischung gehabt aus automatisch generiert,
weil die haben sicherlich für Breath of the Wild nicht jeden Hügel und jeden Felsen
da von Hand gemacht und platziert, das wäre vielleicht zu viel des Guten gewesen, aber
viele Sachen in Breath of the Wild waren halt schön von Hand gemacht und deswegen hat sich
das auch ganz rund angefühlt, wie gesagt, ich mochte die Assassin's Creed Sachen, als
sie noch zum größten Teil Hand gemacht waren, ich weiß nicht wo das aufgehört hat, wahrscheinlich
mit Assassin's Creed 3, die haben jetzt sicherlich auch schon in Assassin's Creed 2 und den
ganzen Ezio Trilogie einiges automatisch generiert, aber vieles war halt da richtig schön gebaut,
naja ich glaube wir gucken uns das Video jetzt einfach mal an, was er zu sagen hat, ne hab
ich nicht gesehen, legit, ernsthaft ich hab das Video nicht gesehen, Laberschelz, ich
schock mich überhaupt nicht, ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht, normalerweise mag ich diese
Epoche und auch Wikinger gedönnt, aber Assassin's Creed Valhalla hat mich absolut nicht geschockt,
ich hab's mir nicht gekauft, nicht mal mit dem Gedanken gespielt ist zu kaufen, ah exzellent,
fangen wir jetzt nochmal von vorne an, Vollbild, Assassin's Creed 2 beste, ja der Ezio war
schon nice, ja nur dass die Epoche, ich hab's mir nicht gekauft, nicht mal mit dem Gedanken
gespielt, ja der Ezio war schon nice, ja nur dass die Epoche, ich hab's mir nicht gekauft,
nicht mal mit dem Gedanken gespielt, ja nur das Ezio war schon nice, ja nur das Ezio war
schon nice, ja nur das Ezio war schon nice, ja nur das Ezio war schon nice, ja nur das
Alter, sah das scheiße aus!
Das könnte sogar schon die grafisch aufgemotzte Variante sein, weil es gibt einen Mod.
Es gibt einen Mod für Gothic 1, der ein bisschen moderne Grafikfunktion hinzufügt.
Nee, das ist nicht der Mod, weil in dem Mod glänzen alle Oberflächen wie verrückt.
Und eins zeigt, noch bevor The Witcher überhaupt mit dem ersten Teil kam, noch bevor Assassin's Creed...
Weil ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob das nicht doch der Mod ist, weil ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob die Weitsicht so gut war im Original.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr, ich kann mich nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern.
Die Animation! Ihr müsst euch mal die Gothic-Animation angucken, Alter!
...mit dem ersten Teil kam, noch bevor Assassin's Creed startete und noch bevor Open Worlds ihren richtig großen Boom erlebten, erschien das RPG.
Das Kampfsystem in Gothic war schon echt big brain, Alter!
Ja, aber es war geil!
Und übrigens, Gothic hat es ja mit den Map-Begrenzungen auch nicht richtig hinbekommen.
Also du konntest zum Beispiel ohne Probleme mit ein bisschen rumgespringe hier raufspringen.
Und historiemäßig war es ja in Gothic so, dass du in so einer magischen Barriere eingeschlossen bist und nicht raus kannst und automatisch gekillt wirst, wenn du rausgehst.
Ja, es sei denn, du bist halt an manchen Stellen gelaufen.
Also du konntest, man kann übrigens direkt am Anfang rausklitschen.
By the way, das machen die im Speedrun.
Aber du konntest auch hier oben hochspringen und dann runterrutschen.
Hier hinten ist dann die Wüste irgendwo, da konntest du dann runterrutschen.
Also es war schon ziemlich verbackt, ja.
Piranha Bytes und war trotz aller Hardware-Anforderungen...
Das Menü! Das Menü! Oder das kaum existente Menü-Inventory-Dingsystem.
Die haben halt echt viel probiert mit Gothic, ne.
Du hattest ja auch zig Sachen in der Welt, wo du mit interagieren kannst.
Du konntest jede Fackel anzünden und sowas.
Aber es war schon ein geiles Game.
Die Dialoge in Gothic waren halt auch geil.
Also vor allem auf Deutsch. Die waren halt schon so...
Die waren eigentlich richtig schlecht, was die Sprecher angeht.
Aber so, dass das irgendwie wieder gepasst hat, ja.
Und was halt auch in Gothic geil war...
Mir fällt jetzt kein spezieller Dialog ein.
Aber wenn du dann das Falsche gesagt hast, haben auch die NPCs gesagt...
So nach dem Motto, ich hau dir aufs Maul oder sowas.
Das war eigentlich genau das, was man von so einer Fantasy-Welt erwarten würde.
Hier, hier! Hier war das In Extremo-Konzert, Leute!
Wer kennt's noch?
Hier, genau hier war... Oder?
Doch, ziemlich sicher. Hier war, glaub ich, das In Extremo-Konzert später.
Da haben sie dann irgendwie einen Sänger und zwei Tänzerinnen oder so auf die Bühne gestellt.
Ein bisschen Publikum vorne dran.
Und haben dann In Extremo-Musik MP3 gedudelt.
Die Orientierung darin und die Verknüpfung mit dem Gameplay an.
Und zeigen, wieso diese eigentlich sehr kleinen Design-Entscheidungen eine große Auswirkung haben können.
Und das alles anhand des Beispiels Gothic.
Und klar, nicht jedes Element hat das RPG selbst etabliert.
Nicht alles taucht exklusiv hier auf.
Es dient vielmehr als Beispiel für eine Art Open World, die heutzutage kaum noch jemand zu kennen scheint.
Das Kampfsystem!
Steckt!
Wenn man nicht gerade Flight Simulator 2020 heißt, steht man als Open World vor einem grundsätzlichen Problem.
Offen Jahr, endlos, nein.
Selbst die schönste Karte muss irgendwo aufhören, anders sind die riesigen Gebiete gar nicht zu händen.
Ey, ich finde, das hat Breath of the Wild tatsächlich ganz gut gelöst.
Die haben das gar nicht versteckt.
Breath of the Wild hat einfach gesagt, hier ist die Welt zu Ende.
Das war's, fertig.
Hier ist die Welt zu Ende.
Ja, und du wurdest dann zurückgepustet.
Also insofern, die haben es gar nicht versucht zu verschleiern.
Endeln.
Es sei denn, man setzt auf die Technik vom... genau.
Also gibt es mehrere Möglichkeiten, die Grenzen der offenen Welt plausibel zu erklären.
Die einfachste Methode ist, eine Insel zu nehmen, wie etwa Ghost of Tsushima.
Dann gibt es natürliche Barrieren und fertig.
Blöd wird das nur, wenn wir in einer Metropole unterwegs sind, die eigentlich auf dem Festland liegen sollte.
Andere Alternativen sind unpassierbare Berge, volle Straßen oder eine unsichtbare Fahrt.
Oder, oder, oder nicht zu vergessen, Call of Duty Logik.
Sie verlassen das Schlachtfeld, kehren Sie um.
Das ist die Call of Duty Logik, die ist so richtig schlecht.
Eigentlich ist die Call of Duty Logik, was World Borders angeht, so mega kacke.
So nach dem Motto, ja, da geht doch die Straße lang und da vorne ist was.
Nein, nein, Sie verlassen das Kampfgebiet, drehen Sie um.
Das ist ein vermeintlich kleines Problem, ja.
Einmal gelöst, bereichert es aber die gesamte Erfahrung.
Und wie macht man das nun?
Na, indem man zum Beispiel den Nach in einen Vorteil verwandelt.
Gothic hat die Begrenzung einfach aufgenommen und als Teil der Welt etabliert.
Der Kern des Spiels dreht sich um das Leben in einem Gefängnis.
Nichts anderes passiert hier.
Wir landen in einer Strafkolonie und die...
Boah, das, ey, das würden Sie heute wahrscheinlich nicht mal zeigen.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, im Intro, im Intro von Gothic 1,
dann wirst du ja in dieses Gefängnis runtergefahren, so.
Und wenn man runtergefahren, auf so einem Minifahrstuhl ist das,
auf so einer Holzrutsche werden die runtergefahren.
Und da liegt auch so eine halbnackte Frau drauf.
Das hätten die heute garantiert nicht beim Intro drin.
Also nicht weil es halbnackte Frau ist, sondern weil die damit indirekt quasi sagen wollten,
dass die sich quasi Frauen irgendwie als Sklaven runterfahren lassen in das Gefängnis.
Das wäre heute definitiv Monkathos.
Das Thema würden die garantiert nicht mal aufgreifen.
Was in dem Setting, was in dem Setting aber passt.
Weil die Levelgrenze nun auch innerhalb der Welt Logik besitzt, bricht die Immersion für uns selbst am Ende der Open World nicht.
Lektion 1 ist also, die notwendige Begrenzung der Welt sollte Teil des Spiels sein.
Sonst erinnert uns immer wieder etwas daran, dass wir eben doch nur ein Spiel spielen.
Wie gut das funktionieren kann, zeigt sogar die Assassin's Creed Reihe.
Hier gehen die erlebten Innerungen eben nicht weiter.
Einfach, aber nachvollziehbar.
Ja, das stimmt, das haben sie gut gemacht.
...Revolution sind hingegen ein viel zu unglaubwürdiger Zufall.
Immortals Phoenix Rising ist wiederum als reiner Spaßort angelegt.
Da passt eine Insel als Begrenzung wie die Faust aufs Auge.
Der Kontext ist also nicht ganz ohne.
Dennoch kann so eine Kleinigkeit wie die logische Begrenzung der offenen Spielwelt doch deutlich ein Atmosphäreplus bedeuten.
Da hab ich mir nie Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Eigentlich ist das richtig Big Brain bei Gothic gewesen.
Dass sie gesagt haben, okay, die Barriere gehört zur Story.
Eigentlich ziemlich clever.
Was Gothic neben dem ersten Kniff ebenfalls wie kein zweiter Titel verstanden hat,
ist der Aufbau der eigenen Welt, sowie die Orientierung darin.
Heutzutage ist es völlig normal, auf einem Minimap oder einen Kompass zu schauen,
sich einfach eine Markierung ins Land zu setzen und schnurstracks auf direktem Wege dort hin zu lenken oder zu reiten.
Questmarker 0W.
Ey, die hätten lieber ihr eigenes Game nicht fertiggestellt damals wahrscheinlich anstatt Questmarker einzubauen.
Oder nicht Questmarker, also Pfeile, wo es lang geht.
Das gab es nicht.
Da gab es das Banditenlager im Westen und solche Dinger gab es dann.
Da gab es kein Pfeil.
... und die Beschaffenheit der Umgebung schnell auszublenden, weil die Landschaft eigentlich...
By the way, by the way, dazu muss ich jetzt sagen, da ist es un...
Also wenn man eine automatisch generierte Spielwelt hat, die sich eben auch ein bisschen so anfühlt,
halt eben keine logischen Punkte, die man sich gut merken kann,
dann ist es natürlich wichtig, dass man Questmarker und Questpfeile hat und sowas in der Richtung,
weil sonst findet man es nicht.
Hat man eine Spielwelt, die irgendwie logisch aufgebaut ist, hat man eine Spielwelt, die man sich gut merken kann,
dann kommt man auch anhand der Beschreibungen von NPCs ganz gut zurecht, wo man hin muss.
Und ich finde, man merkt einfach den Unterschied zwischen handgecrafteter Welt
oder zumindest in Großteilen handgecrafteter Welt und zum größten Teil automatisch generierter Welt.
Weil in Großteilen automatisch generierter Welt findet man sich nicht zurecht,
in handgecrafteter Welt findet man sich zurecht.
Das sieht man, finde ich, ganz gut bei etwas älteren MMOs.
Ich kann beispielsweise in Dark Age of Camelot, kann ich vom Anfang der Welt ans Ende der Welt quasi laufen,
ohne, dass ich irgendwie eine Map oder sowas brauche, überhaupt kein Problem,
einfach weil es einprägsam gewesen ist.
... im nächsten Ort steht. Aber dieser Weg ist essenzieller Bestandteil von Open-World-Spielen.
Oder sollte es viel mehr sein?
Bei Gothic fehlen Hinweise zur Richtung, Standort und mehr komplett.
Wir müssen anderen Figuren genau zuhören, wohin wir eigentlich müssen.
Wenn wir uns ohne Kompass und nur mit Beschreibungen von A nach B bewegen können, macht das Spiel sehr viel richtig.
Wo finde ich das alte Lager?
Du musst nur dem Weg hier folgen.
Wo wohnt der Kartenzeichner Graham?
Der wohnt drüben, links, neben dem Nordturm.
Für all das benötigen wir nie einen Kompass, weil wir uns in der Welt selbst perfekt zurechtfinden können.
Und das liegt gleich an zwei Sachen.
Zum einen ist die Minenkolonie clever aufgebaut.
Wir gehen zu Beginn hier herunter und sehen direkt das erste interessante Ziel vor Augen.
Auch führen Wege sehr klar durch die Landschaft und immer wieder reizen uns Gebäude und Ruinen zum Erkunden.
Wobei die Gegnerstärke eine natürliche Grenze innerhalb des begrenzten Gefängnisses darstellen.
Wir brauchen keine Karte oder ähnliches, um zu den vielen Punkten hinzuwollen.
Das Spiel führt uns etwa zu Beginn mit einem klar erkennbaren Pfad oder Hinweisen von anderen Menschen selbst dorthin.
Zum anderen legt es, genau wie bei der Grenze, wieder einmal die Navigation in die Spielwelt selbst.
Angefangen bei den Beschreibungen der Mit-Häftlinge, die uns wirklich weiterhelfen und nicht bloß einen Punkt auf der Karte offenbaren.
Und selbst die Karte existiert als Gegenstand IN der Welt.
Und die müssen wir uns dann auch erst einmal leisten können.
Zusätzlich hält das Spiel zwar Quests und Lehrer fest, aber fügt nie zusätzliche Informationen hinzu.
Wir klicken hier.
Mit diesem Quest handbuchen wir die Leute heute direkt an und stallen, Alter.
Wir gehen einfach auf einer Liste Missionen durch und markieren sie auf der Karte.
Wir müssen selbst herausfinden, mit wem wir sprechen und wo wir als nächstes am besten hingehen.
Assassin's Creed und sogar das hervorragende The Witcher 3 sehen dagegen alt aus.
Klar, in Städten oder an markanten Orten wissen wir ungefähr, wo wir sind.
Weil wir aber niemals wirklich dazu genötigt wurden mit Hinweisen aus unserem eigenen Spiel.
Da hat er voll und ganz recht, genau das, genau das.
Es gibt ganz viele Regionen, die wir wieder vergessen.
Wie diesen Weg oder diesen Berg.
Natürlich sind bei so einer Größe...
Das liegt aber, wie gesagt, meiner Meinung nach liegt es auch daran.
Klar, wenn du immer nur Questmarken hinterherrennst, das ist das eine.
Aber die Welt ist halt nicht logisch handgecraftet aufgebaut.
Weil man darf nicht vergessen, eine Sache, wo wir wirklich gut drin sind, ist...
Also auch hirnmäßig, evolutionsmäßig, wir sind wirklich gut da drin, Zusammenhänge zu erkennen in Sachen.
Auch total unterbewusst nebenbei.
Das heißt, irgendwas handgecraftet, das ist immer einprägsamer, als was random generiert ist.
Big Brain Logik, ja.
Genau, ja.
Ja, genau so sieht es aus.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Das ist langweilig, das ist auch übelst langweilig, wenn du die ganze Zeit nur Questmarken nachrennst.
Ja, scheiß...
Das ist aber auch nur, weil die Welt da wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil auch noch handcraftet ist.
Ich finde mich in MMOs, die ich lange gespielt habe, auch blind zurecht.
Aber auch nur, weil man eben die Welt richtig erkunden musste.
Und weil man nicht permanent nur Questmarken hinterher gerannt ist.
Wie das bei aktuellen Add-ons aussieht, keine Ahnung.
War das nochmal für ein Game?
Hä?
Ah, das ist Dings hier, PS4 Exclusive Dings gewesen, ich hab vergessen wie es heißt.
Wie hießen das nochmal?
Äh...
PS4 Exclusive, das weiß ich noch, irgendein Zombie-Game.
Nee, nee, das ist nicht Last of Us.
Das ist das mit diesem Motorrad-Ding, ich hab keine Ahnung mehr wie es heißt.
Das war mal irgendwie...
Days Gone, ja das kann sein.
Ja, das war mal irgendwie zwei Wochen angesagt, dann hat es keinen mehr interessiert.
Zombie Apokalypse ist richtig Resident Sleeper.
Ja, da hat er recht.
Äh, also Holistik, ich finde das hängt schon ein bisschen davon ab wie das Game aufgebaut ist.
Und zwar, siehst du, in Witcher 3 hat man es ganz gut gesehen.
In Witcher 3 war auch ein Game, da konntest du, mehr oder weniger, zumindest bei den Side-Quests, konntest du Quest-Markern nachrennen.
So, und wenn man quasi die Novigrad-Quests gemacht hat und nur die Quest-Markern nachgerannt ist, du kanntest dich in der Stadt nicht wirklich aus.
Ich mein, ich weiß nicht, wie es euch gegangen ist, aber ich hatte total oft das Problem, wenn ich nach Novigrad rein oder gerade raus musste, weil ich zu einer anderen Quest musste, ich hab oftmals den nächstgelegenen Ausgang nicht gefunden, weil ich schlicht nach gerade keine Orientierung in der Stadt hatte, wo was ist.
Wäre ich da normal durchgelaufen, hätte mir das Ganze besser eingeprägt, weil ich nicht sinnlos, weil ich nicht sinnlos Quest-Markern nachgerannt wäre.
Dann hätte ich mich da besser, also hätte ich sofort gewusst, wo es lang geht, wo es zum Hafen geht, wo es hier wohin geht, sonst wo.
Aber wenn du nur Quest-Markern nachrennst, du lernst den Kram einfach nicht.
Und du musst die Leute tatsächlich dazu zwingen, das zu machen, weil wenn du die Auswahl hast zwischen Quest-Markern und keine Quest-Marker, irgendwo hast du immer das Gefühl, wenn du die Quest-Marker quasi ausblendest, so nach dem Motto, die Quests sind ja vielleicht gar nicht dafür designed für ohne Quest-Marker und sowas, was sie wahrscheinlich auch nicht sind, wenn es Quest-Marker gibt.
...offen, sondern auch unser Weg darin und das fördert den Sinn und Zweck einer Open World immens.
Lektion 3 lautet daher, eine offene Welt sollte sich positiv aufs Gameplay auswirken und nicht bloß eine Kulisse für ein paar Missionen und Aktivitäten sein.
Entscheidungen und unterschiedliche Wege können dieses Gefühl verdammt gut vermitteln.
Bring mich zu eurem Lager, das will ich mir ansehen.
Sehr gut, ich werde vorangehen, folge mir.
Fassen wir also noch einmal zusammen.
Ja, aber 109, wie auch immer, dann brauchst du ja auch keine Open World, da kannst du einfach Schlauchlevel machen.
Viele Standards in Open Worlds haben sich in den letzten Jahren herausgebildet, um uns ein möglichst stressfreies und angenehmes Leben in den Weiten der Welten zu garantieren.
Dabei vergessen viele Spiele aber, dass eben die Freiheit einer offenen Welt mit einigen Überwindungen und Herausforderungen verbunden ist.
Am immersivsten löst ein Spiel das, in dem es all diese Hindernisse in die Spielwelt selbst hinein liegt.
Das macht die Begrenzungen glaubhafter und die Navigation intuitiver und spannender.
Vor allem aber sollte es seine Open World beschleunigen.
Oh nein, in Gothic konnte man ja auch klettern und springen und sowas, das war auch so ein Ding für sich.
Man konnte hier, das ist übrigens ganz am Anfang hier, man konnte hier hoch und so, die Gothic-Spring-Animation.
Kulisse begreifen, sondern Kontext zwischen sich und den Geschehnissen auf allen Ebenen schaffen.
Wobei, das war noch, das war noch eine gute Kletter-Animation. Die Hochspring-Animation, wo er so die Hände hoch macht, die sieht ganz grausam aus.
Das Erkunden selbst sollte gefördert werden und wir sollten nur die nötigsten Informationen nachgucken können, weil wir sonst einfach nur stumpf die altbekannten Listener arbeiten.
Gothic ist beileibe nicht das erste Spiel, was ich gesagt habe.
Du meinst Red Dead Redemption 2? Hab ich nicht gespielt.
Für den einzigen auf der Welt, der das nicht gespielt hat, glaub ich.
Hier, das war das, was wir eben sehen, ist das Remake.
Outcast, Outcast war richtig Poggers.
Das ist übrigens das Outcast Remake, wo man, glaub ich zumindest, das sieht viel zu gut aus für das ursprüngliche Outcast.
Das ursprüngliche Outcast hatte eine richtig geile Spielwelt damals.
Ach, yes. Rausgearbeitete Lehren von der GameStar. Exzellent.
Cyberpunk schon gespielt? Nee, da hab ich erst mal einen Bogen umgemacht.
In Österreich gibt es einen Ort namens Poggersdorf.
Ja, es gibt auch in Österreich einen Dorf, was sich Fucking nennt.
Die wollten die sich jetzt nicht angeblich umbenennen.
Österreich, Fucking.
Fucking ist ein Ortsteil in der Katastralgemeinde Hofstadt, der Gemeinde Tarstdorf im Bezirk Braunau am Inn in Oberösterreich.
Fucking ist der Ortsname im öffentlichen Interesse.
Heißt nun Fugging, ob das so viel besser ist, ob das Fucking Fugging heißt.
Wie ist das Fugging? Ah, hier. Umbenennung.
Zum ersten Januar 2018 Fugging umzubenennen.
Aber wisst ihr was? Ich glaube, das ist Fail.
Da sind doch bestimmt total viele Leute hingegangen, einfach nur, weil es Fucking heißt, oder?
Also es gibt doch zig Videos von irgendwelchen Amis und sonstigen Sachen, die sich darüber lustig gemacht haben, dass das Ding Fucking heißt.
Nicht, dass die sich ins eigene Fleisch damit schneiden, dass die sich in Fugging anstatt Fucking umbenannt haben.
Die haben das Ortsschild geklaut, ernsthaft?
Die haben das Ortsschild geklaut? Alter, die Leute, ey, guck, das ist so Fail.
Ich habe gedacht, die Leute hätten mal wenigstens Urlaub in Fugging gemacht, oder in Fuggingen, oder?
Oh Mann.
Ja, spiele ich nicht.
Ja, ich spiele ich nicht.
Oh, exellent. Aber das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Sehr schön. Musik anmachen.
Ja, aber es ist, äh, mit schon merkwürdig, ne?
Das ist doch gut. Ey, wisst ihr, Belldelfin verkauft Gamer Girl Badewasser und Zeug, um bekannt zu werden und sonst was, ja?
Und die hier machen das Gegenteil. Die sind schon bekannt, weil sie Fugging heißen und dann benennen sie sich einfach um in Fugging.
Das ist doch scheuer.
Was macht die eigentlich?
Irgendwie interessiert sich keiner mehr wirklich für Belldelfin, oder? Wollte die nicht Ende des Jahres irgendeinen Porn rausbringen?
Ich weiß das nur, Chat, ich weiß das nur, weil der Discord mir das erzählt hat. Sonst weiß ich sowas natürlich nicht.
Ach, es hat die Info.
Das benutzte Kondom will sie verkaufen auf Reddit. Oh, weil. Eins muss man echt sagen, ohne Scheiß. Die hat Marketing komplett durchgespielt, was das angeht.
Und wisst ihr, wer auch das komplett durchgespielt hat? MrBeast hat den Kram auch komplett durchgespielt. MrBeast hat jetzt eine Burgerkette aufgemacht.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Er hat jetzt eine Burgerkette mit irgendwie 300 Restaurants in den USA und angeblich hatten die irgendwie hunderte Meter Schlangen davor, um sich den MrBeast Burger zu holen.
Der macht das richtig. Der lässt nichts anbrennen. Da sind die Stonks real.
Mein Typ ist ja jetzt schon wahrscheinlich Multimillionär, aber spätestens jetzt ist er wahrscheinlich Multimulti-Multi-Multi-Millionär.
Also, richtig Big Brain.
Wie öffnet man 300 Läden auf einmal, indem man 300 Läden gleichzeitig spaut und dann 300 Läden in einem Teil aufmacht?
Und in dem man Geld hat. Obwohl er das sicherlich nicht privat bezahlt hat.
Was für ein Mikrofon? Ich hab immer noch, seit acht Jahren oder so, habe ich dieses Headset und aktuell verwende ich auch dieses Headset mit Mikrofon.
Und dann hab ich auch schon seit ungefähr acht Jahren so ein Ding, USB-Mikrofon, mit dem ich manchmal was aufnehme. Also alles.
Japp.
Gute Frage, zeig mal her, ob ich da was zu sagen kann.
Oh, ich brauche deine Hilfe. Ich suche einen Server-Anbieter, der mindestens vier Terabyte Speicher anbietet für meine Backups.
Ach so, Backups. Okay, Backups. Das heißt, du brauchst eigentlich nichts Großartiges. Du brauchst einfach nur Speicher.
Wie sieht's, Chat? Vielleicht wisst ihr das. Ich weiß es nicht, aber es war früher eine Zeit lang so ein Geheimtipp.
Es gab so einen Google Drive-Upgrade-Plan, der ziemlich günstig war. Nee, nee, AVS und sowas. Wenn man einfach nur Sachen backupen will, da ist das viel zu teuer.
Ich würde irgendwie so ein Low-Budget-Storage-Server irgendwie mal suchen.
Google Unlimited gibt es nicht mehr. Okay. Ja, dann. Ich müsste, wie gesagt, ich müsste mich mit dem Offside-Backup auch mal beschäftigen.
Was gibt's? Komm, wir gucken jetzt mal.
Low End Storage Punkt Win. Klingt sehr vertrauenserweckend.
Okay, es ist so eine Übersicht-Seite. Okay, zeig mal her. Was gibt's da? Storage.
Aber 3T für 10 Euro. Wobei, das kriegt man woanders auch.
Cheap Storage.
Okay, also ich kann dir nicht sagen, was die allerbilligste Sache ist. Schauen wir mal, was die...
Also Hetzner Cloud dürfte ein bisschen zu teuer sein, rein was Speicher angeht, wenn man das nur für Speicher braucht.
Guck, die haben sowas Großes gar nicht.
Du kannst 5T dranhängen, das kostet dann nur zusätzlich 250 Euro. Wir können mal bei der Hetzner Server-Auktion gucken, was es da gibt.
Mindestens 4 Euro. Auch ein bisschen teuer. Das kriegt man garantiert billiger, wenn man ein bisschen sucht.
Was haben die hier bei Storage? Storage Box. Exzellent.
Was haben wir hier? 5T für 6 Euro. Okay, da wird's schon ein bisschen billiger.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz okay. Aber das lohnt sich, finde ich, auch nur, wenn man irgendwie noch ein bisschen was anderes machen will auf den Kisten.
Das wäre mir ein bisschen teuer. Strato High Drive. Strato, Alter, gibt's die noch?
Strato. Ja, nee, also kann ich dir jetzt nichts Gutes raten, aber Offside Backup ist auch so ein Thema, mit dem ich mich unbedingt noch beschäftigen muss.
Jetzt gucken wir uns als nächstes an. Komm, wir gucken uns eine Runde Lockpicking an.
Oder Flirtbots auf... Nein, nein, nein. Chat, Chat, ich weiß, was wir uns angucken. Das müssen wir uns angucken.
Was ist das schlechteste Twitch Emote? Okay, also, bevor wir das Video gucken, ich sag euch jetzt mal meine zwei Hass Emotes auf Twitch.
Also zwei Sachen, die ich überhaupt nicht mag. Und auch wenn ich immer sag, dass Lulvee größer Kekwee ist, oder sag mal drei Emotes, die ich nicht mag.
Ich hab kein Problem mit Kekwee und Lulvee. Also, ich mag Yapp nicht, das stimmt, Crash Fluffy, Yapp.
Und was ich sonst noch nicht mag, ist HaHa. HaHa mag ich nicht. Und was ich überhaupt nicht mag, ist das hier, Chat.
Pogo, Pogo mag ich nicht.
Pogo haben wir nur im Chat, weil der Chat sich das gewünscht hat.
Aber Yapp, Yapp ist ehrlich gesagt so das Emote, was mir am meisten auf den Sack geht.
Und Pogo mag ich auch nicht. Aber Pogo und HaHa. Aber Yapp ist so das nervigste, finde ich.
So siehts aus.
Ich kenn die alle nicht. Den kenn ich, das ist Asmongold. Wer ist denn die anderen Dudes? Ich kenn mich da nicht aus. Ich hab bei Twitch Streamer auch langsam echt den Anschluss verloren.
Wonach hast du eben bei Google gesucht? Du kannst bei Hetzner Storage Box gucken.
Der Typ, der Typ im, das ist laut genug das Video, der Typ im Discord ist einfach nur leise. Der Typ im Discord, das ist quasi Twitch Chat live in real life.
Hört euch den Dapp mal an.
Das ist Twitch Chat, das ist Twitch Chat mit im Discord. Richtig dumme.
Sag doch. Was? Was? Nein, nein, nein, das kann nicht sein. Was? Noch schlimmer?
Also KekW lasse ich mir noch gefallen, aber LulW. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Was für ein Ding?
Jawoll, Jep muss weg, Jep sackt. Jawoll, seh ich auch so. Haha ist echt cancer ey.
Was? Schon wieder?
Oh, jetzt wirds aber philosophisch. Das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden hab, er sagt, er mag KekW nicht, weil jeder Moment, der lustig ist, der normalerweise sein eigenes Emote hätte, jetzt KekW.
Ah, verstehe. Verstehe. Exquisite Logik.
By the way, ich möchte jetzt hier noch mal eine Sache klarstellen, ja. Ich bin 36, sitze Sonntag 10.50 vorm Rechner und philosophiere mit euch drüber, was besser ist und ob KekW nicht die anderen Emotes auf Twitch irgendwie, ja.
KekW ist beste.
Was macht ihr alle gegen KekW? Jetzt wird mal Zeit, dass einer KekDribbleW macht.
Was?
Also, okay, okay Leute. KekW kann ich ja noch verstehen, ja. Aber was kann man denn gegen LulW haben? LulW ist doch eigentlich das beste Lachemote überhaupt. Also LulW ist noch besser als Lul.
Weil, wisst ihr auch warum? Weil Lul gar nicht mehr das originale Lul-Emote ist und LulW ist das originale Lul-Emote allerdings rangezoomt. Man versteht, was ich meine, ne? Also guckt euch mal im Chat an.
Lul ist das nachgemalte, weil TotalBiscuit nicht mal mehr die Rechte am eigenen Gesicht hatte, quasi. Und LulW ist das rangezoomte Original-Lul. Und deswegen bin ich ja immer noch der Meinung, L, Groß L, Klein U, Groß L ist größer als L-U-L, ja. Alles klar, Chat? Könnt ihr mir folgen?
Alles klar, gut, weiter.
Warum wurde er schon wieder gebannt?
Das letzte Emote, an das ich gedacht hätte, ist Smork, Alter.
Was? Das stimmt.
Das stimmt.
Da hat er recht. Oh, was?
Das ist Emote, hab ich völlig vergessen, dass das überhaupt existiert.
Smork ist Pock.
Ja, sehe ich auch so. Haha sagt, das kenne ich gar nicht.
Ja, Pogo mag ich auch nicht.
Beste, ich mag das. Ich mag das Emote. Aber Pogo mag ich nicht.
Pepe.
Was war das jetzt am Schluss?
Hat er da seine Schwester interviewt oder was?
Und wo ist Pogo? Warum ist Pogo nicht dabei?
Also haha gehe ich mit, kack, äh, äh, also hier, ne, haha gehe ich mit, aber der Rest nicht.
Ja, voll einverstanden mit haha sagt, kacke Emote.
Nö, Pogo-Filter. Yep und Pogo müssen da noch rein.
Ne, Kussi, eigentlich haben glaube ich nur drei Leute Pogo gesagt oder so.
Ich lasse es mir gefallen, dass haha drin ist, das ist gut, kacke W überhaupt nicht, weird champ schon mal gar nicht, command bra, ok, ja, kann man sich darüber streiten, aber dass da nicht Pogo drin ist oder zumindest, oder zumindest mal, yep, kann nicht sein.
Dislike ist raus, bam. Ich dislike eigentlich aus Prinzip keine Videos.
Ich glaube ich hab, ist jetzt kein Witz ne, ich hab insgesamt seit ich auf YouTube bin vielleicht, sag mal mal fünf Videos disliked oder so.
Ich mach das eigentlich anders, wenn ich ein Video nicht mag, mach ich es einfach instant aus, fertig.
Ich dislike eigentlich keine Videos.
Außer es ist irgendwas, was ich mit, was mir, wo ich die Leute überhaupt nicht ab kann und ich laufen empfohlen krieg dann vielleicht aber ansonsten.
Oh kurz bisschen Musik wieder an.
Also was ich disliked habe, was ich weiß, als wo du es hier gerade sagst, also was ich disliked habe war der Diablo Immortal Trailer, den hab ich disliked, das weiß ich noch.
Da hab ich mitgemacht, aber ansonsten, was hab ich ansonsten noch disliked?
Ich kann mich nur an den Diablo Immortal Trailer erinnern, den ich disliked hab, ansonsten fällt mir nichts ein.
Ich hab sicherlich noch das ein oder andere Video disliked, aber fällt mir jetzt nichts ein gerade.
Das Frontal 21 Video, ne das hat mich nicht großartig gejuckt, auch wenn der Inhalt bescheuert ist.
Thronax, drei Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive Subscriptions wieder her.
So was gucken wir uns als nächstes an.
Warum hab ich meine eigenen Videos auf?
Hat jeder schon mal ein letztes Cringe Video geguckt oder?
Laut GameStar soll Diablo Immortal gar nicht so schlecht sein.
Das kann ich mir sogar vorstellen.
Ich glaube auch gar nicht mal, dass Diablo Immortal wirklich ein extrem schlechtes Mobile Game wird, wahrscheinlich wird das sogar ganz gut.
Aber das Timing und wo sie das präsentiert haben, das war einfach so fail, wo man gesehen hat, dass Blizzard mittlerweile total detached abgehoben von dem ist, was die Leute sich vorstellen.
Ich meine die können doch nicht auf ihrer Messe auf ihrer hauseigenen Veranstaltung, wo die Leute quasi teilweise aus der ganzen Welt anreisen.
PC, Blizzard, Fanboys.
Da können die doch nicht nachdem fünf Jahre Funkstille war um Diablo Immortal ankündigen und so tun, als wäre das jetzt das, was die Leute sich gewünscht haben.
Das mit den Programmiermemes war geil.
Ja ich dachte mir, dass das nicht jedem gefällt.
Das hat ja auch nur 10.000 Views gekriegt, aber ich fand's lustig.
Hat auch Spaß gemacht aufzunehmen.
Genau Captain Peng, das war das Problem.
Ich glaube gar nicht, dass Diablo Immortal wirklich, wie sieht es damit eigentlich gerade aus?
Dass das wirklich schlecht wird, aber das war, das Timing war einfach schlecht.
Oh, wir haben Diablo und wir hatten richtig, das kann ich mir euch vorstellen.
Maurice am Start.
So.
Okay, an der Seite hat sich auch nichts, der arme Typ, der hat es ja echt abgekriegt.
An der Seite hat sich nichts getan seit drei Jahren, oder?
Oh doch.
Tatsächlich.
Ja okay, es hat sich, es gab vier News, es gab vier News seit zwei Jahren.
Alles klar GG.
Der wurde richtig geflammt, das ist der Typ, der auf der Bühne stand und gefragt hat, ob die Leute keine Telefone haben.
Darum solltest du jetzt keinen PC kaufen.
Okay, zeig mal her, warum, warum solltest du jetzt keinen PC kaufen?
Hey Leute und herzlich willkommen bei Hardware Deals.
Ey, also jetzt mal ernsthaft, wer hat sich da das Intro voneinander abgeguckt?
Hat sich Hardware Rad das von Hardware Deals abgeguckt oder Hardware Deals das von Hardware Rad?
Ich mein, hört euch mal dieses Intro an.
Hey Leute und herzlich willkommen bei Hardware Deals.
Hört euch das mal an und dann hört euch das Intro mal an.
Hallo und willkommen bei Hardware Rad.
Ich find das hat Jules seelig an.
What the fuck?
Hey Leute und herzlich willkommen bei Hardware Deals.
Hardware Rad war der erste, das kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen, weil ich glaub nicht, dass er sich was abgucken würde.
Zumindest kein Intro, Alter.
Na dann, dann sprechen wir drüber.
Na ja, na ja, na ja.
Also, es ist ja nicht so, als müsste man sich jetzt unbedingt einen neuen Rechner kaufen, ne?
Es ist ja nicht so, dass man sagen muss, jawoll, wenn ich jetzt nicht mal ein Geld in neue Rechner investieren kann, dann implodiere ich instant.
Der Kram ist halt teuer und das liegt unter anderem daran, weil AMD was Geiles rausgebracht hat.
Nvidia auch, allerdings Nvidia ist ja bekannt dafür, dass die Sachen teilweise nicht lieferbar sind.
Dass AMD was Geiles rausgebracht hat, alle AMD wollen, aber es zu wenig gibt.
Das ist ja so der hauptsächliche Knackpunkt.
So, deswegen, ich wollte mir eigentlich auch einen neuen PC kaufen Ende des Jahres.
Aber warum, warum soll ich ein Drittel mehr bezahlen oder sag mal ein Viertel bis zum Drittel mehr bezahlen für einen Rechner jetzt, als wenn ich das nächstes Jahr mache?
Ich mein, mein Rechner, der ist ja nicht so, dass der schlecht ist von jetzt auf gleich.
Dazu kommt, dass du kaum noch Grafikkarten kriegst, also es ist Sack halt einfach.
Ich glaube, das einzige, was man gerade bekommt, ist RAM.
Ich glaube Arbeitsspeicher bekommt man ganz gut.
Mir geht es dabei nicht nur um die Verfügbarkeit von Grafikkarten und CPUs, sondern inzwischen ist das Problem einfach viel größer geworden.
Und die ganze PC Szene, Shops und Hersteller und darum natürlich auch wir Verbraucher, werden daran noch einige Zeit zu knabbern.
Also mit BenQ und BenQ hatte ich ja zumindest um 5 Ecken schon mal was zu tun, aber mit VLUX sagt mir gar nichts.
Meiner Meinung nach ist die Situation aktuell sogar noch schlimmer als während der Mining Krise, als man kaum Grafikkarten bekommen hat, weil die Leute einfach anfangen blind alles zu kaufen, sogar alten Scheiß.
Einfach nur um etwas zu kaufen und daran ist mit Sicherheit auch irgendwie die Weihnachtszeit schuld. Aber es macht alles nur noch schlimmer und darum sollten wir unbedingt mal miteinander reden.
Ist das, ist das, was ist das für ein Lüfter? Ist das eine Noctua in Schwarz? Oder ist das was anderes? Kann die Lüfter teilweise nicht mehr auseinanderhalten.
Wie schlimm die Gesamtsituation aktuell genau ist, wie es in nächster Zeit weitergeht und warum ihr euch aktuell wirklich keinen PC bauen solltet und warum es sich tatsächlich extrem lohnt noch ein bisschen zu warten, das schauen wir uns in diesem Video an.
Dieses Video wird euch präsentiert von der neuen Flagschift Tastatur aus dem Hause Corsair, der K-Album.
Ah, yes.
Alter, diese Tastatur, das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt gut. Es ist jetzt tatsächlich mal gut, dass dieser Sellout kommt.
Ich hatte diese Tastatur bzw. den direkten Vorgänger K95. Das war die beschissenste Tastatur, die ich jemals hatte, obwohl die teuer as fuck ist.
Oh, ich weiß nicht, was der K mittlerweile kostet. Guck mal hier, 200 Euro für eine Tastatur und die war so scheiße.
So, und jetzt vielleicht nicht einfach nur um rum zu flamen und jetzt mal konkret zu sagen, was daran scheiße war. War ja wahrscheinlich nicht jeder dabei, als ich mich da mehrere Streams miteinander darüber ausgelassen hab.
Also, das erste, was mir auf den Keks gegangen ist, ist das Layout, aber da kann man sich ja noch drüber streiten.
Dass du beispielsweise oftmals das Gefühl hattest, du drückst G6 anstatt Control. Okay, über das Layout, da kann man sich dran gewöhnen, kann man sich noch drüber streiten, ist okay.
Die Tasten waren rutschig. Also ich bin selten auf einer Tastatur so rumgerutscht wie auf diesen Tasten.
Dazu kamen mir die Tasten relativ klein vor, was aber nicht stimmt, wahrscheinlich sind die Tasten exakt so groß wie alles andere.
Aber das Schlimmste, und was die Tastatur wirklich komplett ins Ausseits befördert hat und warum ich sag das ist die schlimmste Tastatur, die hat direkt am zweiten Tag oder so angefangen doppelte Tastaturanschläge zu fabrizieren.
Das ging dann wieder weg und dann hat eine andere Taste angefangen.
Also ganz grausam. Und doppelte Tastaturanschläge, da hab ich wirklich Anfälle bekommen.
So und dann, ich überleg gerade was der eigentliche Knackpunkt war, warum ich sie ausgetauscht habe.
Ich glaube, weil irgendeine Taste nicht mehr ging.
Ich hab die ja nach einem halben Jahr oder so ausgetauscht.
Vielleicht wisst ihr das noch? Warum hab ich die ausgetauscht damals?
Also es waren doppelte Tastaturanschläge von Anfang an.
Ja doch, ich weiß wieder warum ich die ausgetauscht hab.
Weil, oder zumindest einer der Teile davon, weil V richtig rumgespackt hat mit doppelten Anschlägen.
Ich hab teilweise copy pasted und dreimal pasted und sowas.
Nee, Control ist bei der Logitech Tastatur abgebrochen, das war nicht die.
Die Tasten hielten hier zumindest.
Aber was mir hier nicht gefallen hat, ist auch, dass man ziemlich rumgerutscht ist auf den Tasten.
Aber doppelte Anschläge auf V, das ist das, was mich echt zur Weißglut gebracht hat.
Ich hab was copy pasted und dann hat es auf einmal 5 mal drin oder 3 mal drin oder so.
Das war ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz grausam.
Also ganz ehrlich, für den Preis ist das gebotene wirklich Müll.
Das kannst du nicht machen.
Dazu kommt, was man auch nicht vergessen hat, diese Corsair Software.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich auch noch drauf hab.
Nee, hab ich auch.
Cortana, geh mal weg.
Die Corsair Software ist auch absoluter Crap.
Wir haben ja mal im Stream versucht 45 Minuten ein Makro zu erstellen.
Das ist echt abenteuerlich.
Man kann über die Logitech Software sagen, was man will.
Ich mein, das Ding ist hardcore oldschool.
Aber wenigstens kannst du da drin gute Makros machen.
Also grausame Tastatur.
Ganz, ganz, ganz großer Müll.
Ach ja, was auch Müll ist, die Unterlage für die Handballen.
Die ist viel zu steil und die ist auch viel zu hart.
Es ist alles Geschmackssache.
Aber wo man halt nicht drüber diskutieren kann, ist doppelte Tastenanschläge bei einer 200-Euro-Tastatur.
Auf mehreren Tasten unterschiedlich.
Und gerade bei V für Copy-Paste, das darf nicht sein.
Rest mag alles noch Geschmackssache sein.
Aber das kann es nicht sein.
Exzellent.
Warte mal, hier gab es gerade im Chat noch Q-Questions.
Ja, richtig, so sieht es aus.
Gerade wenn man Stackoverflow Copy-Paste, dann geht das mal gar nicht.
Also man muss ja eins sagen, zu diesen alten PS2-Tastaturen.
Ich würde damit nicht arbeiten wollen, nicht spielen wollen mit so einem fetten IBM-Keyboard oder sowas.
Die Dinger sind ja mittlerweile sehr beliebt.
Aber die sind 50 Jahre später, sind die immer noch so stabil und so resistent, dass du damit erstmal einen Einbrecher-KO schlagen könntest und danach weiter spielen.
Der Fäkalien-Sammler hat abonniert.
Passive-Subscription.
Ich muss dich warnen, in dem Chat hier gibt es nicht so viel zu sammeln in der Richtung.
Weil der Chat ist hier Big-Brain-Chat.
Wie gesagt, das ist alles Geschmackssache, aber doppelte Tastenanschläge bei einer 200-Euro-Tastatur.
Für 200 Euro wahrscheinlich könnte man sich fast was bauen lassen.
Wisst ihr woran es liegen könnte, dass Kopiervorgänge immer auf 99% eine Weile stehen bleiben und generell noch?
Wenn du zu viele Dateien in einem Ordner hast und du hast diesen Ordner im Explorer offen,
oder ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob der normale Explorer reicht oder ob es dieser Datei-Speichern-Dialog sein muss,
dann braucht er lange, um neue Sachen zu erstellen.
Siehst du es? Ich habe jetzt gesagt, neue Ordner.
Achtung!
Wo ist es?
Der hat es gerade gar nicht gecheckt.
Also da ist Windows ein bisschen verbackt.
Habt ihr es gesehen? Habt ihr gesehen, wie lange das laggt?
Das ging schnell. Und je nachdem, wie viele Sachen du drin hast, kann das schon ein bisschen länger dauern.
Und ansonsten? Keine Ahnung.
Es könnte ja auch sein, dass das erstmal in einem Cache landet und die Platte an sich extrem langsam schreibt.
Es kann ja an vielen Sachen liegen.
Aber das mit vielen Dateien in einem Ordner und wenn man dann was Neues erstellt, ist mir schon öfters aufgefallen bei Windows.
Und wenn ihr denkt, mein Desktop hier sieht schlimm aus, der Chat sagt ja immer, mein Desktop sieht schlimm aus,
wobei ich sagen muss, der Desktop, der sieht ja nur wegen dem Chat so schlimm aus.
Guckt euch mal an, was wir hier haben. Wir haben alle möglichen Emotes, die wir, die, ne?
Ist ja nicht so, dass ich die nur für mein Enjoyment hier irgendwie auf dem Desktop habe.
Zumindest, wenn ihr denkt, der Desktop ist schlimm, übrigens es laggt auch, wenn man die Icons markiert, wie ihr seht,
ihr müsstet mal den Desktop sehen von meinem normalen, natürlich sagt, der Chat ist immer schuld.
Natürlich müsstet ihr, ihr müsstet mal den Desktop sehen von meinem normalen User-Account.
Da dauert es teilweise 30 Sekunden, bis ein Icon angelegt ist, weil der so voll ist.
Ich würde den nicht neu aufsetzen. Es bringt ja nichts. Du kriegst ja das Problem immer wieder.
Du kannst die Ordner verschieben. Du kannst die Ordner verschieben in einen Unterordner.
Dann hast du das Problem nicht mehr.
Oh, die Insider hat es jetzt gefixt, nice.
Woran kann es liegen, dass Windows 10 ohne aktive Anwendung schon 3 GB RAM bricht?
Weil Windows 10, glaube ich standardmäßig mittlerweile, Sachen cached.
Das ist aber auch okay, weil ganz im Ernst, wenn man viel RAM hat, was man nicht verwendet, ist es verschenktes Geld.
Also das ist nicht schlimm. Das ist nicht schlimm.
Das heißt nicht zwangsläufig, dass du zu wenig RAM hast für andere Anwendungen.
Also eigentlich ist es sogar gut, wenn ein Betriebssystem möglichst viel den RAM vollklatscht.
Guck mal, ich habe benutzt 10 GB RAM von 32 GB. 10 GB.
Überleg dir das mal für nichts. Ich habe nichts auf, ein paar YouTube Tabs.
Und Windows cached halt ein paar Sachen schon vor.
Hat den Vorteil, wenn du es dann startest, ist es schnell.
Also eigentlich ist es tatsächlich eine ganz gute Sache.
Ich habe OBS offen. Ja, aber OBS. Guck mal, was man es braucht.
Also, wo sieht man den Kram hier?
Memory Usage ist natürlich ganz wichtig, dass das hier so weiter...
Okay, guck mal, wir haben Chrome.
Also Chrome allein braucht ja hier schon mal 3 GB oder so.
Aber der Rest, das braucht nichts.
Also wenn ihr euch das hier anguckt, das sind nie im Leben 10 GB.
Und Windows hat halt irgendwelche Sachen im Vorfeld schon gecached, falls ich sie öffnen würde.
Wohin soll ich gehen? Da hin?
Wo ist das? Da hin?
Ah, hier. Memory.
Okay, Chrome braucht 5 GB.
So, das war es aber.
Also die weiteren 5 GB sind halt irgendwelche gecacheden Sachen.
Macht es heutzutage noch Sinn, Windows ab und zu neu aufzusetzen?
Nö, überhaupt nicht.
Gar nicht.
Ich setze Windows nie neu auf.
Ich habe sogar beim vorletzten PC die SSD umgezogen aus dem alten den neuen Rechner.
Auf dem hier habe ich es jetzt mal neu installiert, weil ich das auf NVMe SSD habe.
Aber trotzdem.
Läuft Windows bei dir in der VM? Nö.
Das ist auf dem Haus drauf, beim Desktop.
Ich habe Linux in der VM laufen, aber auch aktuell gerade nicht an hier.
Also da würde ich mir keine Gedanken machen, wenn das RAM verbraucht.
Das ist eigentlich sogar ganz gut.
Okay Leute, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Was haben wir da gesehen? Flirtbots auf Instagram?
Aja, ja.
Sind Flirtbots auf Instagram ein bisschen was wie weibliche Charaktere in MMOs, die nach Gold battlen?
Das geht doch in die ähnliche Richtung, oder?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das heute noch so angesagt ist,
aber früher hat es in MMOs immer welche im Startgebiet stehen, die haben sich einen weiblichen Charakter erstellt
und haben gesagt, sie sind halt IRL Grill.
Und haben dann erzählt sie nach dem Motto, sie brauchen Gold.
Eigentlich richtig billig gewesen.
Und das haben auch genug Leute gemacht.
Sonst hätte sich das ja nicht durchgesetzt, es hätten nicht immer mehr Leute versucht.
Ich fand das lustig.
Die haben dann teilweise auch richtig versucht, so Mädels in MMOs zu imitieren.
Das waren halt definitiv alles keine Mädels.
Die haben dann halt auch dieses Girlie-Chat-Gehabe versucht in MMOs zu imitieren.
Hihi und sowas in der Richtung.
Also früher in MMOs haben die Mädels immer sowas geschrieben. Hihi.
Diese Kombination, Alter.
Hihi, Nasensmiley.
Ich weiß nicht, was heute angesagt ist. Heute machen die Mädels wahrscheinlich kein Desmiley mehr.
Heute machen die wahrscheinlich permanent irgendwelche Emojis oder sonst wie.
Aber Hihi.
Ach ja, übrigens Leute, die einzig richtige MMO-Lache ist tatsächlich Muhaha.
Ja, es war noch Zeiten, wo man Chats verwendet hat in MMOs.
Heute verwendet man wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil Emojis.
Oder ich würde heute wahrscheinlich Twitch-Emojis in-game verwenden.
Wenn heute einer was lustiges...mach ich ja im in-game-Chat bei allen anderen Sachen auch schon.
Aber wenn einer was lustiges schreibt im Chat oder irgendwas dummes...
Egal ob es die Plattform, das E-Mode gibt oder nicht.
Okay, also gucken wir mal.
Instagram-Flirtbots, zeig ich mal her.
Man kennt das.
Man wird einfach so von einem alten Schulfreund angeschrieben und bekommt recht schnell das Gefühl, dass er das nie...
Nee?
What the fuck?
Geh weg, Windows.
Das kenne ich nicht, weil ich habe kein Instagram und werde prinzipiell auch dort nicht von alten Schulfreunden angeschrieben.
...aus Nostalgie, sondern mit bestimmter Absicht tut.
Und in den meisten Fällen haben wir damit auch recht.
Ich bin auch ehrlich gesagt froh, wenn mich keine alten Schulfreunde anschreiben.
Wenn mir die gar nichts mehr zu tun haben.
Instagram ist dieses Problem ähnlich, nur dass uns der Gesprächspartner nicht um Geld oder ein gutes Wort beim Arbeitgeber bittet,
sondern ein lukratives, freizügiges Angebot macht, das sich immer wieder neu zu unterbieten scheint.
Ich finde es ja auch witzig, dass sich die Flaume und die Aubergine als Emojis für, ihr wisst schon, durchgesetzt hat.
Gibt es morgen ein Venise an Livestream?
Ja, wenn das morgen wirklich rauskommt, wirklich.
Wie habt ihr euch kennengelernt?
Na ja, sie hat damals unter meinem Instagram-Bild ungefragt.
Ich denke, meine Brüste sind zu groß.
Pfirsisch, Pfirsisch, keine Flaume.
Ja, okay.
Meinetwegen Pfirsisch.
Aber kommt doch, es sieht doch fast genauso aus.
...verschwitzt kommentiert zu werden scheint, sollte man...
Okay, also wenn jemand ungefragt unter einem Instagram-Bild bei mir kommentieren würde,
ich denke, meine Brüste sind zu groß und verschwitzt, wird man da nicht ein bisschen misstrauisch?
Denkt man sich dann, ach ja, ach so, ja, ja, also jetzt wo du es sagst, kann ich mir das mal etwas näher angucken?
Ja doch, finde ich schon.
Also die sind schon ein bisschen zu groß und verschwitzt.
Also ganz mal ernsthaft, wer kennt es nicht?
Toponautin ist vier Monate, danke schön für den Sub.
SamusKlima!
Und passiert.
Instagram hat mittlerweile über eine Milliarde Nutzer weltweit.
Laut externen Untersuchungen ist etwa jeder Zehnte davon ein Bot.
Das einfachste ist, kein Instagram haben, dann hat man das Problem nicht.
Naja, ist ja klar, ist ja klar.
Mit den Bots kannst du Geld verdienen, mit den anderen nicht.
Echt?
Ja, ich mein, man darf nicht vergessen, Belldelfin ist auch auf Instagram bekannt geworden.
Und die Frage ist natürlich, ist das Video sogar echt und nicht gefotoshoppt?
Ist das wirklich ein echtes Gras und ein echter Sonnenuntergang?
Naja, wahrscheinlich eine Mischung aus Geld, Malware verteilen und Scam.
Scamas halt.
Ja, klar.
Stomps.
Ja, gibt ja auch genug Lowbright Leute, die auf sowas reinfallen.
Wer fällt auf sowas rein? Ganz ehrlich, mir ist es unerklärlich, aber das sind die gleichen Leute, die früher auf Viagra-Sperm reingefallen sind per Mail.
Also die gleichen Leute vom Gehirn her, bloß jetzt halt 30 Jahre jünger.
Es reicht ja auch, wenn einfach von, keine Ahnung, wenn du 10.000 Leute anschreibst, das kostet dich ja im Endeffekt nichts großartig.
Und davon fallen, keine Ahnung, vielleicht eine Handvoll drauf rein, reicht schon.
Natürlich, natürlich.
Ha, geile Entwicklung, geile Chat, wer kennt's nicht, wer kennt's nicht?
Hallo, was machst du denn so? Ich finde mich hier gerade zu recht.
Ha, auf welchen Frauentyp stehst du denn so? Natürlich, wie aus dem Leben, ja.
Ach du Scheiße.
Gibt's hier einen Schnoch? Ich habe schon lange nichts mehr gehört. Vorbei, ich will auch gar nichts hören.
Wisst ihr, was der erste, was muss ich jetzt gerade echt nochmal kurz erzählen, wisst ihr, was der erste Channel war, wo ich Katja Krasavitz, wie man hier ausspricht, wo ich die zuerst gesehen habe zum allerersten Mal?
Ben Luxor, kennt ihr mal noch Ben Luxor? Der, der, äh, was weiß ich, der Mülltollen-Verschönerungsexperte und sowas.
Ha ha, das war, ich fand das übelst lustig. Den gibt's ja nicht mehr, der hat irgendwie seinen Channel verkauft oder sowas. Ben Luxor, alter, kennt ihr noch jemand?
Der Weltverschönerungsexperte, Typ, der war richtig geil. Ich weiß nicht, warum der seinen Channel verkauft hat.
Den gibt's ja nicht mehr, aber der war geil.
Chatmoderatoren, wie sie auch euphemisiert werden, obwohl sie entgegen der geläufigen Bedeutung dieses Wortes weder Nachrichten löschen noch Nutzer sperren, sondern sich je nach Schicht eine andere Sockenpuppe aufziehen und die Identität eines solchen Profils übernehmen, um die Opfer dieser Masche zu antworten und damit zu zahlen.
Sind ja auch nur Weiber da, ne? Ganz klar, sofort, nachdem du dich angemeldet hast. Alle, die warten nur drauf.
Ne, das macht irgendeinen Bot mittlerweile.
Den gibt's nicht mehr, ne? Nein, der hat seinen Channel verkauft. Vielleicht ist der mittlerweile wieder da, aber der hat seinen Channel verkauft.
Ach guck mal.
Und gibt's den echt wieder?
Ne, das ist irgendwas anderes. Das ist überhaupt nichts von dem.
Das ist der doch gar nicht.
Das ist irgendwas anderes. Der Typ hat seinen Channel verkauft.
Oder was auch immer. Das hat mit dem gar nichts zu tun, ne?
Und das sind auch alte Videos, die er neu hochgeladen hat.
Warum verkauft man seinen YouTube-Kanal? Wahrscheinlich, weil man es nötig hat.
Oh, wir wollten uns ja eigentlich angucken, warum man sich jetzt kein PC kaufen soll.
...ist, obwohl die Plattform mittlerweile den Einsatz von Chat-Moderatoren in ihren AGBs angeben.
Und die Antwort ist, vielleicht.
Denn man darf nicht einfach so irgendwelche Sachen in die AGBs schreiben und wer sie nicht liest, der hat dann Pech gehabt.
Sondern die daran enthaltenen Informationen dürfen keine überraschende Wendung für den Nutzer bereithalten.
Das bedeutet, eine Plattform, die mit Partnern fürs echte Leben wirbt, aber dann IKM-Schreiber nutzt, könnte vor Gericht eine solche überraschende Wendung nachgesagt werden.
Welche Tastatur empfindest du für die Arbeit?
Also ich finde die Ducky One Skyline ziemlich gut, mit NumBlock, die hier.
Oder mittlerweile fahre ich die Ducky One 2, kann auch sein.
Ich habe die alte noch mit NumBlock, das da.
Mit NumBlock.
Wo ist der NumBlock? Ich will den mit NumBlock.
Nicht NumLock.
Block.
Inner.
Beste.
Richtig gut.
Habe ich auch schon eine Weile auf der Arbeit.
Was ich gemacht habe, ich habe noch so kleine Silikonringe unter manche Tasten, wo ich besonders heftig immer drauf haue, dass ich meine Mitarbeiter auf der Arbeit nicht so sehr nerfe.
Weil ihr kennt mich ja, ich habe ja so einen Tick, wenn ich Sachen eingegeben habe und sie nochmal Probe gelesen habe, dann haue ich beispielsweise ganz gerne mal auf den NumBlock, auf das NumBlock Enter und sowas.
Da habe ich beispielsweise, also ich habe einen Ring unter dem NumBlock Enter.
Ich glaube unter Control und normalem Enter und Backspace oder irgendwie sowas.
Welche Switches, boah das weiß ich nicht mehr, kann ich dir nicht mal sagen, was ich die gekauft habe.
Das, was damals die Fault Standard drin war, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich kenne mich damit auch nicht wirklich gut aus mit mechanischen Tastaturen.
Also ich kann euch da nicht viel raten, ich hatte ein paar, alle waren scheiße, bis auf die Ducky One Skyline und die aktuelle Logitechnik, die ihr habt, geht auch halbwegs.
...fake-Profile von unterbezahlten IKM-Schreibern authentisch wirken lassen und ihre Opfer über kostenpflichtige Nachrichten ausnehmen. Psychologisch ist das extrem manipulativ, denn es wird da anscheinend erweckt, dass es der Gesprächspartnerin sehr ernst mit uns ist, schließlich erscheint sie auch Geld für Nachrichten an uns zu zahlen.
Die Plattformen selbst betreiben aber nicht die Bots auf Instagram. Hier findet sich erneut ein Affiliate-Netzwerk ähnlich wie beim Scam auf Facebook wieder.
Die Plattformen beschäftigen Drahtzieher von Bot-Armeen, die die Link-Platzierung an die höchstbietende Plattform verkaufen.
Nachdem UWG dem Gesetz gegen unlauteren Wettbewerb ist allerdings diese Art der direkten Kontaktaufnahme zur Kundenakquise hierzulande illegal.
Ja gut, dann verfolgt das mal auf Instagram, goodluck.
Telefonanrufe und analoge wie digitale Post dürfen in diesem Fall nur noch ausdrücklicher vorheriger Einwilligung geschehen.
Das ist doch dem China-Bot egal.
Man kann es sich wieder sehr einfach machen und herab vom hohen Ross seiner eigenen Medienbildung, die selber Schuldkarte zücken und damit auch nichts ändern.
Was allerdings hilft, ist sich über derartige Maschen bewusst zu sein, ähnliche Muster woanders wiedererkennen und sich selbst und andere schützen zu können.
Das ist ja überhaupt nichts Neues, dieser Scam.
Und die Dunkelziffer der Opfer ist wahrscheinlich ziemlich hoch, denn die Scham auf einen im Nachhinein so offensichtlichen Betrug hereingefallen zu sein, ist bei vielen zu hoch, um damit zur Polizei...
Ich hab euch ja schon erzählt, dass mein Vater früher was ähnliches gemacht hat, Leute gescampt auf ähnliche Art und Weise.
Also das ist nicht neu und das hat er 1980 gemacht.
...die die Abzockplattformen keine Opfer mehr hätten, ist ebenso wenig zielführend, einfach weil ein solches Gesetz technisch nicht umsetzbar ist.
Es wäre ja so, als würde man einer Software sagen, sie solle den Unterschied zwischen einem Zitat und einer Urheberrechtsverletzung erkennen.
Aber das macht ja zum Glück keiner.
Und da wurde freigesprochen.
Und der Richter muss damals wohl noch irgendeine gefragt haben, also die haben sich den Vertrag angeguckt, den die Leute so unterschrieben haben.
Und der Richter muss damals wirklich jemanden noch gefragt haben, ja warum haben sie das so oder warum haben sie sowas denn überhaupt unterschrieben?
Also sprich der Vertrag muss schon extrem einseitig gewesen sein, ja.
Und also man sieht, wenn mein Vater auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise Leute 1900, frag mich nicht, 85 bis 1990 rumgescampt hat, das ist nichts neues.
Und das wird's immer geben, das wird's immer geben, plus halt in anderer Art und Weise, ja.
Chatpots auf Instagram.
Tja, gut, ich hab kein Instagram-Account, mir fallen da auch keine Chatpots auf.
Wir wollten übrigens das Video angucken, warum man sich grad kein PC kaufen soll, fällt mir auf.
Schaut mein Vater aus wie ein russisches Model.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, der hat das anders gemacht.
Der hat Partnervermittlung nicht für Männer gemacht, sondern nur für Frauen. Und der hatte Männer, die halt im passenden Alter sind, gut ausgeschaut haben.
Und halt im Prinzip den älteren Damen mehr oder weniger alles erzählt haben, was die hören wollten.
Und die Mädels fanden das halt dann ganz toll und haben halt gedacht, oh ja, wie hat der Asitoni gesagt, das ist der Mann fürs Leben.
Und haben halt munter weiter Beiträge bezahlt.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, ein paar fanden es sogar richtig gut.
Also, tja. Wie gesagt, die Masche ist nicht neu.
Es ist nichts Neues bei, ja.
Genau, also warum sollen wir uns keinen neuen PC kaufen?
Ich überspringe mal kurz die Werbung, weil ich hab mich ja schon zu dieser Tastatur ausgelassen, dass ich den Vorgänger grausam schlecht fand.
Das findet ihr in der Videobeschreibung. Die Idee zu diesem Video ist aus genau zwei Gründen entschattet.
Exzellent.
Erstens, weil sich in letzter Zeit eine bestimmte Art Kommentar auf diesem Kanal und auch meinem Instagram und Twitter-Account häuft.
Und zwar die Art, die man eigentlich nicht lesen möchte.
Ich und auch meine anderen YouTube-Kollegen werden nämlich teilweise extrem angefeindet.
Das ist normal. Immer. Du kannst auf YouTube nichts machen, wo nicht irgendwie Leute sich angegriffen fühlen.
Also, ich bin sehr beleidigt, weil die Leute sauer sind, dass sie die PCs und Komponenten, die wir empfehlen, nicht kaufen können.
Ey, Kusswort. Nix gegen E-Girl-GG, ja.
Oh, ePAL ist es ja mittlerweile.
Ich bin eher für eine 30-90 bei dem 1000 Euro PC-PC, weil dann bekommt man wenigstens eine Grafikkarte für das Geld.
Sonst halt nix.
Auch die neuen 35.000er CPUs, was, wenn man die UVPs anschaut, absolut realistisch wäre.
Aber was bringt es mir, euch irgendwelche Komponenten zu empfehlen, die man überhaupt nicht kaufen kann aktuell und wenn dann halt nur zu absolut kranken Wucherpreisen.
Ich mein, im Kern macht man das Problem damit ja nur noch schlimmer.
Denn man erhöht die Nachfrage für ein Produkt, was man aktuell nicht oder nur in winzigen Mengen kaufen kann und dadurch natürlich auch irgendwie den Preis, also Angebot und Nachfrage eben.
Schauen wir uns mal kurz den aktuellen Markt an.
In letzter Zeit sind einige echt coole neue Komponenten vorgestellt worden.
Die RTX 3080 zum Beispiel, eine Grafikkarte, die ich selbst reviewt hab und die vor allem für ihre geile Preis-Leistung gefeiert wurde.
Ja, okay und warum sollte ich mir jetzt keinen Rechner kaufen? Jetzt komm mal zum Punkt.
Ich wusste zu dem Zeitpunkt halt nicht, dass man die Karte in absehbarer Zeit nicht für die UVP bekommen wird.
Schlimmer noch, wenn wir mal bei Geizhals nach einer RTX 3080 schauen, die UVP ist übrigens 699 Euro.
Ja, das ist, wenn der Scheiß neu ist, immer so und das geht mir auch auf den Sack, dass mittlerweile die meisten Launches so laufen.
Es kommt irgendwas Neues raus, der Hersteller sagt irgendeinen Preis, es gibt dann so wenig davon, dass man teilweise monatelang gar nichts kriegt und wenn man was kriegt, kostet es ein Drittel mehr.
Auf den ersten Blick vielleicht, dass es ein paar Karten gibt, aber wenn man dann genau hinschaut, dann sieht man, dass es meistens nur 1-2 Shops sind, die die Karte anbieten.
Und wenn man dann mal die Vorbestellungen ausblendet und nur nach Shops sortiert, die die Karte auch liefern können, naja, dann sieht es eben ziemlich mau aus.
Auf Ebay wird die Karte inzwischen für knapp 1200 Euro gehandelt, also das Doppelte der UVP.
Bei der RTX 3070 gibt es tatsächlich nur einige Shops, die die Karte auf Lager haben.
Ob sie die Karte auch wirklich haben, sei jetzt mal kurz dahingestellt, auch da habe ich schon einiges erleben müssen, dazu später mehr.
Aber der günstigste Preis...
Wisst ihr was Big Brain wäre? Wenn ich Hardware-Shop wäre, dann würde ich den 3090 anbieten fürs Doppelte und dann, wenn einer es bei mir kauft, kaufe ich es bei Ebay und schicke es an den Typ weiter.
Das sind halt 699 Euro und das, obwohl die Karte eine UVP von 499 hat. Bei der RTX 3060 Ti sah es kurz nach dem Launch echt gut aus, aber auch da inzwischen der günstigste Anbieter Computer Universe mit 569 Euro...
Leerverkäufe, quasi sowas in der Richtung, ja.
...mit einer UVP von 399 Euro. Und bei dem Handy bin ich mir auch tatsächlich unsicher, ob die Ware auch wirklich auf Lager ist.
Ich habe da mal selbst Zubehör für unsere Studiolampe bestellt und zwar bei dem Shop, weil sie die kürzeste Lieferzeit hatten.
Naja, bestellt hatte ich im März und das Lieferdatum war ursprünglich der 2. April.
Ab dem 2. April habe ich dann wöchentlich E-Mails bekommen, dass die Ware nächste Woche kommt und angekommen ist sie dann viele Monate später und zwar am 28. September.
Exzellent. Und genau so werden viele Shops aktuell vorgehen, um Vorbestellungen zu sammeln und zwar indem sie relativ kurze Lieferzeiten vorgaukeln und die dann halt Woche für Woche immer wieder nach hinten schieben.
Man muss also wirklich aufpassen aktuell. Von den AMD 5900 CPUs müssen wir eigentlich auch gar nicht erst anfangen. Nur kurzen Blick auf den Ryzen 7 5800...
Ey, das ist nicht normal, wenn du dir sowas heute kaufen willst. Es gibt welche. Also ich wollte mir einen 5900X kaufen. Das kostet 5900X.
So, guckt euch mal die Preise an. Okay, okay, okay. Also normalerweise sollte das 599 kosten, das kostet 57. Also das kostet einfach mal 200 Euro mehr.
Der Preis schwankt zwischen 440, was sehr nah an der UVP ist und knapp 700 Euro. Das große Problem ist aber, dass die Leute das tatsächlich für diese Preise kaufen und damit...
Ja, das ist echt das Problem. Ganz ehrlich, dann würde ich mir, wenn ich mir jetzt was kaufen würde, dann würde ich mir tatsächlich lieber nochmal ein Intel System kaufen, weil das preisleistungsmäßig einfach attraktiver ist.
Es ist doch bescheuert zu sagen, okay, AMD hat eigentlich die bessere Hardware und das bessere System und normalerweise ist es preisleistungsmäßig auch wirklich angemessen.
Aber dann 200 Euro mehr für auszugeben, ergibt ja gar keinen Sinn.
Den Preis halt immer weiter nach oben schießen lassen. Inzwischen sind selbst in Anführungszeichen alte Komponenten wie der Ryzen 5 2600 und 3600...
Ja, das ist total hängen geblieben.
Ich meine, der 2600er ist innerhalb eines Monats von 112,50 Euro... Ja, also das ist hängen geblieben. Das ist irgendwie 4 Jahre, 5 Jahre alte CPU oder?
Nee, ich kann es nicht. 4, 4, 3, 3, 3 bis 4 Jahre. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, wer so bescheuert ist.
Schauen wir uns mal ein Mittelklasse-Modell wie die RX 5700 XT von AMD an. Die günstigste Karte kostet 475 Euro, ist also innerhalb der letzten zwei Wochen um sage und schreibe 20% gestiegen.
Richtig hängen geblieben. Richtig hängen geblieben.
Wichtig ist, dass es bei den Nvidia-Karten die Vorgängermodelle quasi gar nicht mehr gibt. Die günstigste 2080 Super kostet zum Beispiel einfach mal 900 Euro.
Und wie gesagt, das ist halt so, weil die Leute den Scheiß immer noch kaufen und zwar auch zu solchen überteuerlichen Preisen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und es zieht sich wirklich durch alle Bereiche, bei RAM ist es jetzt dadurch, dass bei Micron ein Stromausfall war.
Stimmt! Ich habe es nur am Rande mitbekommen.
noch schlimmer geworden, das sieht man schön am preis vom g-skiller aegis kit das ist einfach innerhalb der letzten drei monate von
46 auf knapp 60 euro gestiegen also über 30 prozent aber ramm ist aber ramm muss man ehrlich sagen ramm ist im vergleich von vor
2 3 jahres ist immer noch zaubermäßig billig geworden das führt dazu dass zum beispiel selbst mein 700 euro pc also eine konfiguration
die von den neuen rtx 3000 und ryzen 5000er releases eigentlich gar nicht betroffen ist inzwischen knapp
900 euro kostet der pc ist innerhalb von zwei wochen um 200 euro gestiegen
und jetzt stehen wir eben vor dem weihnacht einfach kein pc kauft dass die nachfrage noch weiter nach oben steigt und es gibt natürlich mit
cyberpunk 2077 ein spiel was auch viele dazu bewegen wird aufzurüsten
da habe ich so meine zweifel ob die leute jetzt noch wegen cyberpunk aufrüsten gleich sogar einen komplett neuen pc zu holen
und ich kann an der stelle nur eins sagen kauft euch aktuell kein pc lasst es einfach denn es gibt eigentlich nur zwei
das ist auch so ein wettbewerb wer kann mehr rgb lüfter einbauen sein rechner die eintreten können
erstens ihr bekommt zwar einen pc aber zahlt viel zu viel dafür und glaubt mir in ein paar monaten werdet ihr euch darüber ärgern
wie macht man eigentlich so coole kamerafahrten
kein pc lasst das muss man auch auf irgendeiner schiene machen oder
Szenarien die eintreten können erst oder wie macht man so was aber zahlt viel zu viel dafür und glaubt mir in ein paar monaten
werdet ihr euch darüber ärgern wenn ihr 2000 euro für einen pc gezahlt habt der dann nur noch die hälfte kostet oder zweitens
ihr bekommt den pc zwar den ihr bestellt habt aber halt viel
der tisch dreht sich
das wird sein denn auch das ist ein punkt an dem
beide weltes sind diese lüfter wo irgendwie 31 euro kostet oder das sind auch diese korsar rgb
fragt mich nicht sonst was wo irgendwie lüfter 30 euro oder sowas kostet was auch fragwürdig ist betrieben wird und viele shops die
blauäugigkeit der nutzer ausnutzen ich meine ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass 99 prozent der leute die jetzt bestellen ihre geräte noch vor weihnachten
bekommen wollen bei agando zum beispiel ist ein pc bestseller nummer eins der gleich zwei der heiß begehrten komponenten an bord hat
ein ryzen 5 5600 x und eine rtx 3070 für
1649 euro was zwar viel zu teuer ist aber lassen wir den preis mal beiseite er ist der aktuelle bestseller
selbst sucht man aber vergeblich nach einem hinweis was die lieferzeit angeht erst wenn ich rechts in der konfigurationsseite nach unten scroll dann gibt es
moment fahrkreis 6 fahrkreis gibt es noch gar nicht
vorbestellung handelt mit unbestimmtem liefertermin im warenkorb dasselbe spielchen
und ich will jetzt gar nicht diesen speziellen shop dafür an den pranger stellen agando hat sich in der letzten zeit wirklich
gebessert denn genauso gehen aktuell 90 prozent der shops vor auf teufel komm raus überteuerte
vorbestellungen sammeln die wahrscheinlich erst im monat bedient werden was ziemlich sagt und so was sollte die als verbraucher auf keinen fall
unterstützen denn erstens ganz ehrlich ich eure produkte erhalte war ganz ganz im ernst wenn
irgendwo einen shop drinne stehen hat ist es ja auch schwierig zu erkennen wenn irgendwo einen shop drinne stehen hat
der produkt xy lieferbar in in in zwei bis drei werktagen und das ist in zwei bis drei werktagen noch nicht losgeschickt
und
die stellen sich irgendwie quer mit geld zurück da mache ich direkt bei paypal käufer schutzgedöns auf
deswegen mache ich das auch nur nur über amazon pay oder paypal ich habe überhaupt kein bock mehr mich mit irgendwelchen
freitränen shop anbieter auseinanderzusetzen
hat ihr gerade einfach utopische preise dafür ich meine wieso zur hölle sollte man etwas vorbestellen ich diskutiere überhaupt nicht mehr mit den rum
es ist gut möglich dass es anfang des jahres einige große schwinge der neuen komponenten gibt und dann fallen die preise halt wieder Richtung
uvp und ich glaube nicht dass dann irgendjemand der idiot sein möchte der sich ein paar wochen vorher alte hardware zu überteuerten preisen gekauft hat
einfach nur um überhaupt einen pc zusammenstellen zu können
manchmal heißt es eben einfach geduld haben und genau das sollte jetzt das oberste gebot sein ja das stimmt wirklich schwierig und viele wollen
wie gesagt mir juckt mir juckt es auch schon seit über einem jahr in den fingern neuen rechner zu kaufen aber es gab halt noch keine gute
gelegenheit und ich sehe es auch nicht ein wenn ich mir eh schon rechner bauen normalerweise um die
was weiß ich 4k oder so kosten wird ungefähr so über den daumen gepalt
dann sehe ich nicht ein als 5k dafür auszugeben einfach um ihn jetzt zu haben das wir so hängen geblieben
ich sehe aber dieses mal solltet ihr wirklich verzichten bescheuern warum soll ich das machen ein ärgern und es gibt auch alternativen
wenn es wirklich um ein weihnachtsgeschenk geht dann verschenkt zum beispiel einfach gutscheine für pc shops dann kann der beschenkte sich
einen pc gönnen wenn sich die preise wieder normalisiert haben und wenn ihr unbedingt cyberpunk 2077 oder ein bestimmtes
spielen wollt und aktuell kein pc oder vielleicht eine alte krücke habt gönnt euch das spiel einfach auf google stadia geforce now oder einem anderen game
stream aber habe ich gerade zum ersten mal wirklich eine empfehlung für google stadia gehört
hat er hat er gerade wirklich gesagt google stadia sich das habe ich richtig gehört
streaming dienst wie shadow damit könnt ihr die wartezeit gut und vor allem günstig über
jedenfalls hoffe ich dass ich euch mit diesem video ein bisschen zum nachdenken bringen konnte denn auch wir verbraucher die unbedingt und
koste es was es wolle die neuen produkte haben wollen sind schuld daran dass die preise in astronomische höhen ja gut und wer hat er hat auch
youtuber die am fließband videos zu dem besten gaming pc für xy euro produzieren mit komponenten die man gar nicht kaufen kann machen die
sache natürlich nicht also eher oder ich habe mir gerne mal in die kommentare was ihr von dem ganzen thema so haltet und ob
ihr dieselbe meinung teilt wie ich oder ob ihr die aktuelle preissituation vielleicht sogar gerechtfertigt findet ansonsten bedanke
ich mich einfach für eure zeit und gerechtfertigt gerechtfertigt ist es ja ganz klar wenn die leute in kram kaufen für den preis
natürlich ist es gerechtfertigt ist aber dumm sich das dafür zu kaufen
du du du du du du exzellent ok chat gucken wir uns jetzt an how many potatoes does it take to run doom what the fuck top 10 3d gedruckte weihnachtsgeschenke
ok jetzt gucken wir uns das an vielleicht dann noch was geiles bei vielleicht dann noch vielleicht dann noch was gutes dabei weil
wer einen 3d drucke hat bis weihnachten jetzt auf vier tage zeit aber wir machen es jetzt im schnellen wir machen das jetzt im schnelldurchlauf
wir gucken uns jetzt ok in den schwert will ich mir nicht ausdrucken
ok seine boxen hat er auf jeden fall auch 3d gedruckt das haben wir glaube ich im letzten video schon mal gesehen das ist das ist ein teleprompter die
prille wir haben uns mal ein video von dem typ angeguckt das ist irgendwie so da steht der text drinne den er vorliest ist das quasi singiverse für
für arme oder was sangs warum nicht gleich denks so ein stupsinn warum soll ich mir so was ausdrucken warum soll ich mir so was ausdrucken das ist total sinnlos
was ist aus google class geworden nix
ja aber das ist doch kein 3d gedrucktes weihnachtsgeschenk ok ok wenn du kinder hast vielleicht
ok wer freut sich nicht darüber den 3d gedruckten corona virus zu weihnachten zu bekommen
so
so cute die most important feature of this particular print is that you get
to save the recipient coronavirus if you disregard social distance
erst mal drauf husen vor bescheid ja side note i printed this little guy out
of the most bizarre filament i've ever seen this is purple p.t.g. not pl a and it
glows green in the dark also it's full of glitter weird this principal virus
makes an appropriate ornament or even only sardonic tree topper but it's the
remixes that really send this to epidemic proportions here's a rona for
your extruder here's a rona that holds your masks here's a rona to open your
corona some americans may fear the rona less than others but they'll change
their tune once they see the buff
number eight lift pod photographers and videographers are the worst people to
buy gifts for because everything okay ne das brauche ich nicht next maybe you're
doing office secret santa and you got gary who never talked to anyone has no
social media and only wears plain unique low t-shirts who the hell knows
what's going on inside your head gary when you don't know what they want give
them something nobody absolutely nobody asked for download a crossbow that fires
peanut butter cups okay peanut butter cookies oder so was das ist ja so eine
typische kokona geschichte ich glaube so was gibt es hier gar nicht
okay das braucht man auch schon mal nicht
puzzle puzzle brauche auch nicht gift card brauche man auch nicht ein cute ein
cute dumpster eine eine eine niedliche mülltonne
exzellent
cute dumpster
warum warum sollte ich also also was warum warum warum denn cute cute dumpster
number three lithofen ist eine 3d man auch nicht weigend 250 was das triple
that's a wine say hello to number one the cyclone the triple lift triple track
marble machine weigend 200 das braucht doch auch absolut keine sau
taking 18 hours or longer to print this group of loops shoots and circuitous
routes is an absolute three intertwined marble raceways dance and weave through
a rub goldberg in masterpiece and a built-in hand cranked Archimedean screw
carries the balls back up to run again it's a gorgeous intricate model that
exemplifies the creative potential 3d printing it's hard to believe that this
didn't need any supports or glue this model prints beautifully with absolutely
zero support or extra materials at all I even use PETG which is a lot also so ein
ding auszudrucken in der kürze da braucht man 3d drucker wahrscheinlich 30
stunden für
place and cleaning out the tunnels what you see here is exactly what came off
my printer even the marbles can be 3d printed although in my opinion is
echt so ist echt so du benutzt das du benutzt das einmal und danach steht's
rum
depot to grab some ball bearings the cyclone is truly a low effort high reward
print that anyone can make but when it gets unwrapped you are gonna look like a
mastermind you and your giftee are guaranteed to be the center of attention
till the piss 5 finishes downloading 200 gigabytes of day one patches and that my
precious present but i had to suck the piss 5 nice is 10 unique and impressive
gifts that you can run off in time for x-mas a friendly reminder we just open
the void star lab
richtig sinnlos richtig sinnlos akakona musik exzellent
weiß ich warum ich offen hatte aber
was kommt man als nächstes an
how much does multiplayer population matter er kommt auf das gelbe an
jetzt gucken wir uns nicht an kommt wir gucken uns das neue alpha 4 games video
an was heißt neu vom 1. december schon 19 tage alt ich hab es aber nicht gesehen
alpha 4 games beste was haben wir ansonsten mein favorite desktop und das
ist wieder was wo ich mir drüber aufregen muss weil es unten sinniger crap ist
danach gucken wir uns auf our battlefield 4 trickshots an exzellent
warum hat es 368.000 aufrufe warte und gute bewertung
people forehead
ok kommt uns alpha alpha 4 games was hat er für neues der bisherige erfolge von
amazon games der bisherige erfolge von amazon games ist relativ einfach
zusammenfassbar paar games released zum größten teil alles crap
sachen wieder eingestellt kennt ihr noch diesen diesen overwatch schräg strich
moba verschnitt den sie da hatten ich habe schon wieder vergessen wie es
halt crucible hieß es genau crucible amazon was sie wieder eingestellt haben
wo sie rausgebracht haben festgestellt hat die leuten finden es scheiße
danach gesagt haben aber wir machen das neue beta und dann wieder ein akumal das
gibt es nicht mal mehr auf der seite und dann wieder eingestellt die haus
richtig verschissen
so krepp
was moment mal da muss ich jetzt mal crucible reddit wir gucken mal ob es
ob es da noch leute crucible ok gibt es da irgendwas hat das jemand
interessiert 3,2 1000 es ist ja nicht das hatte
wirklich absolut niemand interessiert
crucible 2
ganz bestimmt kann man sich die ergebnisse angucken
crucibles man sieht man sieht ja daran mal wieder auch die größten kack fail
games haben eine gewisse fanbase
k
mein was man kann für game of the year voten warum
was
ok was auch immer gucken wir uns mal das gucken wir uns mal das video an
amazon ist uns schon seit einer ganzen weile im video spielbereich tätig sie
haben ihren eigenen pilot wings music excellent das stimmt ja das war das waren
die ersten paar dinger diese da entwickelt haben die haben also die
ersten paar sachen diese gemacht haben waren halt app store dinger ok daran
daran kann man jetzt ist die nicht unbedingt messen
aber man darf man abgesehen die spiele die danach kamen war auch kacke
sie haben mit der lamba ja das ist es ist lamba ja hat nicht das wo sie
kritec die cry engine sachen lizenziert haben
spiel engine die auf der cry engine das video ist eigentlich laut genug oder
soll ich den tick lauter machen passt eigentlich genauso wie die cry engine
niemand freiwillig nutzen will ja aber lamba ja ist ja cry engine oder
zumindest jemand der jemals fertig wird und nun seit ein paar Jahren sind sie
ebenfalls ganz vorne mit dabei ihre eigenen spiele zu verkaufen beziehungsweise
eher zu veröffentlichen weil verkaufen ist dann auch mal was anderes und wieso
auch nicht amazon ist mit einer der größten firmen der
welt jeff beases ist der reichste mann der welt
am reichsten an dem klingt er äußerst motiviert bei dem video muss ich sagen
oder seiner angestellten die infrastruktur ist also da die ressourcen
erst recht der ausflug in die feucht fröhliche welt der dadelein joysticks
und unbezahlten überstunden ist da nur der nächste natürliche schritt wenn
irgendjemand da draußen den großen publishern zeigen kann wie man es
richtig macht dann definitiv nicht aber so wohl aber die coolen leute würden
natürlich auch amazon sagen
crucible ist ein oh nein hör mal auf crucible
arena mit diesen fiechern da im key art und das mit seinen zeitlosen erst mal
was musik alter crucible das war so ein fail schon längst vorbei ist im spiel
kann man rumhüpfen eine niedrige kamera haben
und das man kann auf gegner schlagen oder auf gegner schießen das ist
animal crossing und die halbe todesanimation die überhaupt abgespielt wurde
ich muss ehrlich sagen ich habe es nicht ausprobieren ich habe es mir nur ein
paar mal auf twitch angeguckt und crucible hat mich so hat mich insin so
extrem abgeschreckt dieses game dass also dass das in die hose geht das
hätten die eigentlich selbst erkennen müssen
das sieht richtig pains jam aus zu spielen
ganze zeit nachgucken wie die steuerung noch mal geht
wir sehen nach irgendwie zwei minuten oder so vorgespult habe um zu sehen ob
man dann noch etwas anderes macht also dasselbe ding
sieht nicht so aus also anscheinend habe ich mal gehört habe ich in so einem
kommentar gelesen soll das gameplay das video hast du schon mal geschaut nee ist
nicht schon mal geschaut so aussehen wie das von paragon nur schlechter
paragon ja das da hätte ich tatsächlich da wäre ich gespannt drauf
gewesen was bei paragon rauskommt paragon ist das was epic games entwickelt hat
bevor fortnite das riesen ding geworden ist was blöd ist weil paragon schon vor
ein paar jahren abgeschaltet wurde das schafft mal schlechter zu sein als
etwas das gar nicht mehr existiert und so hockte man sich hin hörte auf das
feedback der fans und passte bei amazon sein spiel noch ein wenig mehr an seine
vorlage an ich weiß noch als mein netzwerkschef damals extra meinte ich
soll mich gefälligst beeilen ein video zu machen bevor crucible down ist ich
habe mich nicht beeilt ein video zu machen bevor crucible down ist
ende mai kam es raus nach sorgfältiger marktforschung also dem gucken nach den
spielerzahlen merkte man dass es keiner spielte und schrumpfte dann in
förderform zurück in die close beta oder hat man es eingestellt spielte um jetzt endgültig abgeschaltet zu
werden weil es keiner spielte herzlichen glückwunsch es dauerte nicht mal ein jahr
und jetzt spielt es sich wirklich genauso wie paragon
dazu gibt es ein game dazu gibt es ein game wer braucht denn dazu ein game
entwickler gecancelter familier spielen auf einer engine die nicht für rennspiele
geeignet sein soll kommt nun das interaktive spielerlebnis für ein bis
null spieler dass uns hinter das länkrad der ikonischen szenen der show
the grand tour setzt ich schau ich schau die serie auch nicht regelmäßig
guck mal ab und zu mal in eine folge rein weil ich zwischendurch mal ganz
lustig finde man echt gar nichts zu tun hat aber ja also wer braucht dazu ein
game szene aus der show und da fahren wir dann so lang dann ist er das beste
ui design der videospielgeschichte und plötzlich bist du need for speed
payback gelandet fährt in der show jemand geradeaus fährst du nun selbst
gerade das macht man sehr oft stirbt in der show fast jemand durch einen
unfall stirbst du nun selbst fast durch diesen unfall das macht man nicht so
oft ein spielbares dvd menü ein interaktives best of tiefer borgen unter
chromatischer aber ration von family guy funny moments die fachpresse meint zwar
dass das spiel absolut nicht gut sei aber ganz ehrlich wer kauft sich so was
für streckendesign oder fahrzeughändling wenn der gesamte reiz doch
offensichtlich darin liegt gewalttäter mittleren alters beim lenken zu helfen
für die zielgruppe hat sicher charm der typische fall von fans greifen zu alle
anderen spielprobe das kostet 61 auf steam nicht dass es jetzt auch irgendjemand
überprüfen könnte denn wenn wir schon nicht den erfolg von anderen
rennspielen kopieren können kopieren wir halt deren business
entscheidung wer braucht schon code masters die ihre spiele alle paar jahre
aus sämtlichen stores nehmen wenn man sie auch schon nach eineinhalb jahren
entfernen kann ok sorry leute wie gesagt wir waren nicht mal klar dass es zu
dieser serie überhaupt ein spiel gegeben hat und geschweige denn warum man das
spielen will aber lizenzen sind nun mal teuer
besonders so einer selbst produzierten show sind sie einfach astronomisch wir
müssen uns außerdem sowieso auf andere projekte konzentrieren
das schreiben wir im faq faq zum auslauf von pissbottles weil es ja auch so viel
arbeit kosten würde ein spiel nicht zu löschen fans der show müssen sich nun
also wohl oder die war es wahrscheinlich selbst zu peinlich den der krab mit
jedem anderen renn spiel jemals zufrieden geben oder mit der demo von
probe breakaway ist oder war oder wird nie ein hero base sport von der
existenz dieses spiels habe ich auch nie was gehört es sieht ein bisschen aus
wie so einen wie so ein arena bettel game so ein bisschen was wie bettel
riet oder bettel right oder wie das hieß
brawler das im subgenre der nein danke ich weiß mal nicht spielen spieler
smite ok bei denen so also bei dem so heroes rumlaufen und da ist ein ball
der sound klingt die ganze zeit so komisch ach du scheiße also ok das ist
ja auch wirklich mal kompletter vernichtung von ressourcen was amazon
da macht ja weil ich gehe mal davon aus dass keiner der leute die da dran
arbeiten wirklich bock hatte da dran zu arbeiten das spiel kombiniert elemente
von rocket habe ich das habe ich das mal habe ich das richtig gesehen
relay e-sports dass die wirklich versucht haben da irgendwie ein auf
e-sports zu machen in dem game das ist irgendwelche teams sind elemente von
rocket league power stone und league of legends und wurde was ist power stone
sehr leicht und komfortabel auf twitch gestreamt zu werden noch mal in den
sack greifen kriegen wir vielleicht sogar noch ein paar mehr spiele namen
aufgelistet außerdem ist es mittlerweile relativ schwierig geworden etwas auf
twitch zu streamen das auf grund mangelnder nachfrage gar nicht erst
erschienen hat amazon eigentlich mittlerweile mal irgendwie was halbwegs
erfolgreiches rausgebracht das einzige was mir dazu einfällt ist die bringen
ja demnächst in mmo und bisher waren die stimme nach den beta tests ganz ok was
ich so von den leuten gehört hat manche sachen fanden das extrem nice
manche haben gesagt ja ganz unterhaltsam aber genau new world genau und aber ich
habe jetzt wenig leute gehört die zu new world gesagt haben alter ist der ultra
crap schlechthin also new world scheint wohl das erste halbwegs ganz ok mäßige
spiel zu sein von amazon
wollen die nicht auch neues herr der ringe game machen zu ihrer neuen herr
der ringe serie
so guter letzt schauen wir uns mal an was aus new world so wurde das sollte ja
mai raus ist immer noch beta beta beta die haben aber man muss aber sagen mit new
world die haben da auch wieder ein paar dinge gemacht wo ich mir gedacht habe
ein bisschen fragwürdig zum beispiel sollte dieses game ja ursprünglich mal
ziemlich pvp fokus werden und dann ist ihnen aufgefallen dass irgendwie rein
mit pvp fokus nichts zu holen ist und jetzt ist es irgendwie so ein so ein so
ein pvp pvm hybrid oder so ob das so gut ist mal gucken ich habe die bilder nicht
gespielt oder so vielleicht mal rauskommen ein mmo rpg von und für leute
die hoffen dass es nicht noch einmal verschoben wird
worüber die meiste berichterstattung bisher eher negativ war polygon bezeichnete
den inhalt des spiels als fragwürdig IGN macht eins dieser alles was wir bisher
wissen videos in dem sind dann auf sieben minuten gestreckt sagen dass sie
noch gar nicht so viel wissen und ich war schon seit tagen also ich muss sagen
also ich wie gesagt ich habe selbst nicht gespielt aber alles was ich bisher
von leuten den ich halt auf so auf twitter folge gelesen habe die das
gespielt haben es war nichts dabei was jetzt wurde das ultra scheiße fanden
der lost hat es gespielt der fand es ganz ok der dings hier wie heißt er der
der wie heißt der channel der sascha wie heißt davon eben noch mal der channel
overwatch heroes nie er ist er denn ich bin gerade voll steckert voll auf dem
schlauch
heißt wie heißt der channel von dem overwatch
highscore heroes highscore hier die hat auch gespielt er fand extrem nice
ja paar leute deswegen also alles was ich bisher zu dem game gehört habe und
auch was ich so ein bisschen bisschen reddit mäßig gelesen war ganz in ordnung
also nichts zu vergleichen mit dem anderen fail was amazon bisher abgeliefert
also new world könnte tatsächlich ganz ok werden
eine bestellung los schickt weil ich ohne socken ich wirklich einkaufen gehen
kann 0 zu 3 gegen euch also hoffentlich wird es der massive erfolge dem an sich
verspricht jetzt nicht das glaube ich nicht also das glaube ich nicht also
da fehlt da fehlt nur mit sicherheit wirklich der so der geniale funke
irgendwie dass das so wie hat man früher gesagt der world of warcraft killer
wird ne ich glaube das können wir uns ja eh abschminken das juckt ja auch
kein mehr aber dass das ein game ist was millionen leute da rein bringt jetzt
mmo glaube ich nicht vor allem spiele mit heftigen pvp fokus sind jetzt
allgemein nicht so beliebt was millionen an spielerzahlen angeht
wo hat ja auch kein heftigen pvp fokus war hat einen nice mal zumindest früher
ein nice arena modus gehabt wo es auch wirklich darum geht dass die leute gut
spielen konnten aber das war nie der hauptfokus von dem game
und naja
zwei jahre online oder so irgendjemand ist bestimmt gespannt doch da
tatsächlich da und da muss ich dem thema widersprechen ich bin wirklich
gespannt was aus new world wird ich glaube wie gesagt nicht dass es der
nächste neue klasse wow killer oder sowas wird also wirklich spannend was
daraus wird weil ein pvp style pvp fokus mmo da gibt es meiner meinung nach viel
zu wenige die halt auch irgendwie langfristig spaß machen ja mal gucken
mal gucken ich glaube aber auch nicht dass es das der riesen mega erfolgt
wird
widerspeile die seit mindestens sechs jahren geplant haben feuert aus allen
rohren und sieht bisher genau exzellent joshua island musik ein erfolgsjagd den
anderen all das gelte sichtlich gut angelegt die aufgekauften richter teams
sind sicher zufrieden mit dem was sie bisher vorzeigen durften ja das ist das
was ich von oba das ist riesen ressourcenverschwendung aber was amazon
da treibt und ich würde mir jedes spiel davon mindestens gleich flipp alter
herz 39 flipp was buddelt du jetzt mit uralte mmos aus einer kämmerle hat
dings die heißt ja immer noch so kämmel hat unshänt soll ja auch demnächst
rauskommen ja ne wird nie rauskommen wahrscheinlich wenn es überhaupt
möglich wäre schalten wir den job mode aber für
einen moment mal wieder aus ich finde es unglaublich mit was für
eine arroganz und selbstsicherheit amazon in diese industrie eingestiegen
ist mit den größten planen von einer großen internen engine einem spiel
amazon amazon kann ja gar nicht anders das ist amazon amazon kann ja nicht
irgendwie einsteigen und sagen ja gucken wir mal wie sich das ganze so
entwickelt die machen das sind stonks leute die machen immer erstmal auf
große auf dicke hose ohne das was dahinter ist
erobern sollte dem großen mmo schlechthin und sobald neue spiele unter
neuen ja der käme alle irgendwie ungefähr sieben jahre her und es ist
nicht mal ansatzweise vorzeigbar wurden sie schnurstracks einem nach den anderen
exekutiert ist eigentlich wie sieht es eigentlich mit star citizen aus
mittlerweile gewesen machen sie einfach weiter mit mehr und mehr konzepte erdacht
von führungspositionen die nur eine tech der techwillen showcasen sollen und man
dann stolz auf seine 10.000 spieler gleichzeitig sein kann der inhalt ist
erst mal zweitrangig seit einfach unfassbar teuer das ist unser nächstes
spiel teuer und um dem ganzen am ende noch seine krone aufzusetzen haben sie
ihren großen cloud gaming streaming service tm angebracht das habe ich ja
schon wieder komplett verdrängt amazon will ja bei dem ganzen
game streaming geschehe es auch noch mitmachen jetzt muss kassaume
interessiert ja und stadia ja eine riesen erfolge worden ist von dem alle
gerechnet haben ja man muss sich ja immer mal nur die spieler bei destiny
angucken stadia ist aber einem prozent aufgerundet gekündigt und damit so bete
ich dankeschön für den sub 07 excellent subscription so hart auf die schnauze zu
fallen denn das was die welt kooper tritt spiel dankeschön weiterer gaming
service der videospiele wie austauschbare netflix produktion behandelt aber amazon
ist bei der sache echt ein bisschen spät die haben alle angefangen wo stadia
losgelegt ist und nach dem was google macht spiele streaming wir brauchen
jetzt auch ganz schnell spiele streaming oder man hatte vielleicht schon spiele
streaming und dann hat man festgestellt bei google läuft nicht so gut an der
brauche auch kein spiele streaming mehr handeln wird von einer firma die so
schon mit ihren eigenen spielen umgeht und die erst vor kurzem darauf
bestanden hat dass kunden ihre selbst erworbenen produkte gar nicht besitzen
und man sich das recht vorbehalten möchte kunden diesen digitalen besitz
wieder wegzunehmen ja das hat das war auch gerne wenn ihr
den video kaufs bei prime da können sie der könne sie dann sagen auch nö
gibt sie mir film bezogen aber wenn man da schon so hinterher sein möchte sind
videospiele nicht weit es passiert echt nicht häufig dass man gleich alle
masken auf einmal fallen lässt wobei sie in diesem kampf gegen konsumenten ja
sowieso genug gleichgesinnte finden würden das ist nicht nur dreist sondern
in dieser kombination auch noch erstaunlich gefährlich amazon hat jetzt
schon in diesem kurzen zeitraum den ich hier beleuchtet habe deutlich bewiesen
wie egal ihnen videospiele an sich das stimmt wie wenig respekt sie haben
also amazon geht es auch komplett am arsch vorbei amazon stoch er so lang im
dunkeln bis da vielleicht mal einen hit rauskommt oder was halbwegs
brauchbares und dass wir dann gemolken bis zum geht nicht mehr
könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern dass amazon flappy bird gekauft hat wer kann
sich da noch dran erinnern flappy bird das war auch so ein
ding wo man nicht verstanden hat naja egal den machern von diesem medium und den
konsumenten haben sie haben bewiesen dass sie auch in diesem
bereich nicht mit samt handschuhen angefasst werden sollten dass man
zukünftigen projekten kritisch und skeptisch gegenüberstehen sollte und sie
abseits vom versandhaus möglichst wenig mit gaming und der gaming szene an sich
zu tun haben sollten ich bin übrigens auch wieder auf twitch
unterwegs weil alle anderen streaming plattformen langsam pleite gehen außer
plextorm folgt mir also am besten auch mal dort wir haben da immer lustige zeit
was für ein ding plex was spielt ab und zu meinen videospeil das ist von
namaz exzellent
hat's verlegt so so muss das sein exzellent ein bisschen promotion muss
immer sein ja hat er recht ja bisher nichts auf
die reihe gebracht und die werden in nächster zeit denke ich auch
nichts richtig gescheites auf die reihe bringen wenn du wollt rauskommt einmal
dahingestellt aber ich bin tatsächlich auf nur ein bisschen gespannt
ich glaube da hat auch kein intro mehr intros gehen auf youtube 2020 nicht mehr
oder nicht mehr gut
Leute ich bin immer noch mit beginn das war ich bin jetzt schon seit zwei
stunden oder so an ich bin gleich ein und ich muss mal aufs klo das ist
schlechte kombination
in us youtube req gibt es viele intros es gibt noch einige channels mit intros
ja aber die meisten haben entweder keine intros oder die machen das
besonders trickreich die machen in den in den teaser von 30 sekunden dann
kurzes intro und dann geht es von vorne los
warum kommen intros nicht gut weil die leute kaum noch aufmerksamkeit spanne
haben wenn du das video direkt mit dem intro
anfängt sind die leute nach fünf sekunden direkt weg
du musst du musst einen teaser machen dann ein intro und dann mit dem video
anfangen das geht aber direkt am anfang den intro kannst du nicht mehr machen
nope exzellent funktioniert nicht mehr
schauen wir uns jetzt noch an komm wir gucken uns das eine runde bettelfield 4 top
top place an muss jetzt muss jetzt mal sein morgen kommt kommt wenn es an
liege draus oder oder um nicht zu sagen moment moment habe ich sie noch drinnen
ne habe ich nicht mehr drinnen moment moment moment
was ja auch für erheiterung im letzten video gesorgt hat da wollten leute
wirklich wissen wie ich das wie wie nice wie ich das gemacht habe
wirklich wissen wie ich das wie nice wie ich das gemacht habe natürlich wird
das nicht verraten dass ich stream geheimnis
so gucken wir uns mal eine runde bettelfield 4 an schreckt schreckt
warum fällt das tut nicht um oh nice da ist das da hat man aber auch gesehen
bettelfield server und tick rate man muss mal ganz ehrlich sagen
das eine hat mit dem anderen jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu tun was man da
sieht und was da passiert ja
also das was man sieht und das was passiert hat nicht so wirklich gesunken
miteinander der muss noch ins 360 einbauen dann ist das legit ansonsten
zählt das nicht nicht abgenommen nicht legit
he did send in a few clips the second one is again a snipe in clip using the
cs on dawn breaker an eight man in total for this one
aber er ist voll reingesprungen der typ das jetzt in der hinten die map heißt
auf deutsch übrigens morgendämmer alles klar der morgendämmere
und dann die 3rd und final clip ist enttänzt in switching out zu
something a little more close range ist die uts 15 operation locker und der
wird krass geflammt er tut danach shotgun typ mit kill streak der kriegt also
wenn es ist pc ist es keine xbox und keine playstation
der würde ansonsten hate voice messages bekommen da nach ja das stimmt die
erste map war das mit dem mit dem radioteleskop was von paar wochen kaputt
gegangen ist
greedless ist next the first of a few odd clips that I've had sent in that I
thought it included this one well I'm gonna slow it down in the replay for you
after you're watching exactly what he does you can tell me what happens
according to the chat why is that a nice man why is that a mit explodiert
jetzt
well I'm gonna slow it down in the way for you after you're watching exactly
what he does you can tell me what happens according to
warum explodieren hier das ist ja gold motorelle da liegt doch hier liegen doch
versteckt so bomben da liegen doch auf der strecke so so so so minen drum da
hat er sich wahrscheinlich mit luft gesprengt ja genau jetzt habe ich es
kapiert
he hits the ID taking out a few vehicles including one in the air was jeep see for
incredible luck
was
achter all das hätte aber nicht gesehen also das war wirklich nicht aufgefallen
dass er noch ein heli dabei ist also bei ernsthaft wer hat das gesehen am
anfang ich habe jetzt den panzer hier gesehen okay aber dass ein heli
rumgestellte ist noch nie
zu den kriegt er auch so 30 milliarden punkte
das klick ist von walkable mango 42 he's on hannam walkable mango alles klar
on the roof and look what he does next look what he does next das kann ein richtig guter
clickbait titel sein oder oder was was was auch sehr beliebt ist
zehn zehn geschenk zehn weihnachtsgeschenke die jeder die jeder
braucht du wirst niemals glauben was nummer vier ist oder oder
unglaubliche heck battlefield spieler hassen diesen trick oder solche dinger
lunger 09 ist coming in with an attack helikopter clip i do love the attack
helikopter if you've got a pilot that can hit this damn dominate the skies three
in a row proving that it's skill das muss er erst mal treffen das ist echt
nicht ohne
genau unglaubliche entdeckung beste waffe in battlefield da muss am besten
auch so was dahinter wie unglaubliche entdeckung beste waffe in battlefield die
niemand kennt oder irgendwie sowas oder die beste waffe irgendwie sodass die
quasi jetzt erst entdeckt wurde du bist der erste der ist der welt erzählt
nur mit dem unterschied dass in bed bed company 2 die dinger viel langsamer und
größer waren in bed company 2 so ein transport heli mit dem at4 zu hitten
war jetzt nicht so krass schwer es hing natürlich immer davon ab wie gut der
typ geflogen ist wenn der typ richtig gut geflogen ist was saumäßig schwer
aber die meisten konnte man gut hitten die attack er die die die transport
helikopter in bed company 2 war ja auch recht langsam und fett die attack
helikopter waren in bed company 2 auch größer und langsamer in battlefield 4
sind die dinger halt viel schneller und kleiner
also das ist wirklich nicht ohne ist das die community map ich kenne die map
nicht ist ja was das coole ist wenn wenn es an licht wirklich gut ankommt die
haben wir sogar einen map editor
und da kann man sowas theoretisch selbst machen hidden weapon found after 10
years in battlefield 3 genauso was sowas muss so da machen richtig
das ist kein feind moment woher wusste er dass da einer ist was da los was da
los hat er an hat er an ist das release da ist
von wenn es an licht bekannt ja morgen ok ok jetzt gucken wir mal wo hat er das
erkannt
ach moment das ist doch ein ach das ist ein gegner das ist nur der nametag von
einem team hat hinten dran das ist das ist doch ein gegner gewesen ich dachte
es ist ok ok alles legit legit da hat er noch mal glück gehabt sonst werde ich
hier gleich meine jungen langjährigen dais kontakte benutzt ja gleich da
hätten wir gleich stehen den den dicker nick oder wer auch immer das ist
immer gleich ins sind ins sind wackband ich hätte direkt ich hätte direkt in
stockholm angerufen exakt hier das geht nicht der dass sie
koin wackband weiß das kämmen nicht mal wack hat also die werden hart
geschreckt die gegner
ja so was von offen aufs maul die gestern alter falla guckt euch das mal
an es schießt auch keiner zurück
du war die waffe von sich aus so genau oder musste man zumindest noch ein
bisschen recoil kontroll machen
alligator auf Sack
2 Klips von Tessio Bruno, der erste wird auf dem Operation Locker mit dem CZ-3A1 stehen,
geflogen hinter dem Ausflugsplan, aber das läuft nicht rated a bunch of time.
ACWR oder so, ne?
Die waren beide richtig gut.
Also die AI-Kan Battlefield 3 muss ich euch sagen, ich hab lieber eine M16 oder M416 benutzt,
weil das Reload von der AI-Kan war halt wirklich lahm.
Vor allem wenn du nicht aufgepasst hast...
... mit dem... und alles leer geschossen hast.
Also man muss ja eins sagen, die schaffen es echt immer Gegner zu finden, die absolut
braindead sind.
Aber so macht es halt Spaß, wo man wieder sieht, fuck skill-based matchmaking, so muss
das sein.
Du brauchst einfach ab und zu mal irgendwelche krassen Achievements.
Es erwartet ja keiner, dass es konstant so ist.
Man kommt morgen Venice an Liesch draus, wenn das dann irgendwie mit 23 Joule rauskommt
oder spiele ich das auch nicht?
Ich hoffe, die denken an EU-Time.
Das ist wahrscheinlich 30% oder vielleicht ein bisschen höher.
Ich habe wirklich genossen, dass es so ist.
Das geile ist bei den Gegnern, die reagieren noch nicht mal, wenn sie angeschossen werden.
Ja keine Reaktion, der Typ kriegt in der S geschossen und dreht sich nicht mehr um.
800er-Ping-Chinese oder was ist das?
Ah yes, Betro.
Guck mal, hallo Gegner, please.
Mach die Augen auf, Alter.
Guckt euch an, guckt euch an.
Der macht es schon gut mit dem Flanken und alles, aber die Gegner tragen schon den beträchtlichen
Teil dazu bei.
Battlefield 4 hatte so eine komische Mischung mit Tick-Rates.
Ich frage mich nicht, was in die Voll-Tick-Rate ist, aber die hatten in Battlefield 4 so ein
komisches System eingebaut, dass dort, wo Action auf der Map ist, die Tick-Rate höher
ist als dort, wo keine Action ist.
Irgendwie so.
Das war sehr merkwürdig und das haben sie auch erst nachträglich eingebaut.
Kennen wir das schon?
Das kennen wir schon, ne?
Übrigens, das ist wirklich die beste Pose im ganzen Game.
Jaja, das kennen wir schon, das kennen wir schon, das haben wir schon gesehen.
Wurden sie weggebashed.
Battlefield 3 nervt einfach, dass man um die Ecke ist und 3 Sekunden später stirbt, ja,
das stimmt.
Dafür gefällt mir Battlefield 3 an sich vom Gameplay her am besten.
Also, Chet.
Hier muss man übelst aufs Klo, aber ich hab jetzt kein Bock Stream auszumachen, wir gucken
jetzt noch was zusammen.
Haben wir denn hier noch Interessantes zu gucken?
Opening a Lock with Explosives, exzellent.
Das ist der Lockpicking-Lawyer, und heute, in der Woche, bei Independence Day in den USA,
feiern wir die 241.
Anniversarier der 13 Kolonien, die klären, dass sie eine neue Nation sind, die independent
von dem britischen Empire ist.
Und ich wollte mit einer entsprechenden Art, diese Begegnung anzupacken, also habe ich eine
gute Art, das zu machen, wäre für mich, ein amerikanischer Lockpicker, einen britischen
Lockpicker zu wählen.
Exzellent.
Also bin ich in meiner Kollektion und suchte einen britischen Lockpicker, den ich euch nicht
vorher gezeigt habe, und ich kam mit diesem Squire, WS75, der in Briten gemacht wurde, und
wie perfekt ist das, es hat sogar die britische Flagge auf dem Lockpicker.
Aber dann ist es passiert...
Eins muss man ja sagen, in einem Punkt ist UK wirklich größer US, und das ist bei den
Einheiten.
Ich meine, in den USA, wenn du bei Amazon guckst, wie schwer ist eine Maus, dann steht
dann irgendwie was, 7,3 Ounzen oder sowas, also Ounces, was zum Teufel soll das sein,
ja?
Also was Einheiten angeht, ist wirklich, Freedom Units ist schlimm, da sind die in England
besser.
Die verwenden wenigstens zum größten Teil, zum größten Teil normale Units, ja?
Und hier haben wir auch wenigstens ein Datum in der richtigen Reihenfolge in England.
Oh, jetzt wirds aufgesprengt.
Hast du schon von der Paketabgabe gehört für den Onlinehandel, ne, was soll das sein?
Es war doch sogar mal so, dass bei der Internationalen Raumstation was nicht gepasst hat, weil die
einen in Freedom Units gerechnet haben und die anderen metrisch.
Das war ne Rakete, kann sein, aber ich kann mich nur dran erinnern, dass es halt versagt
hat, weil die Einheiten unterschiedlich waren.
Auf, sprengs in die Luft, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf,
auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf,
Ich will einfach nur sehen wie es explodiert
Lad auf oder füll es rein
Oh da hat sogar so ein extra Startding
Wie ich will sehen wie er das reinfüllt
Oh wir dürfen gar nicht zugucken wie er das reinfüllt
Wahrscheinlich darfst du das auf YouTube nicht zeigen, weil dann YouTube das Video sperrt
Okay wo explodiert es?
Okay und jetzt ist es aufgesprengt
Okay das hat es mitgenommen
Also wenn das nicht ein super amerikanischer Weg ist Independence Day zu celebrateen dann weiß ich auch nicht
Wir sprengen was in die Luft
Also mehr Kokona Style geht ja eigentlich gar nicht
Wie ist eigentlich jetzt wo wir gerade beim in die Luft sprengen sind habt ihr das verfolgt?
Ist es jetzt erlaubt oder verboten Feuerwerk zu machen an Sylvester?
Mich persönlich tangiert es ja nur so am Rande
Ich mache ja schon seit Jahren kein Feuerwerk mehr
Erlaubt aber es ist nicht mehr kaufbar
Okay das war es
Es ist nicht mehr kaufbar
Okay das bedeutet die Leute kaufen sich das dann im Ausland oder wie?
Okay Hessen
Gucken wir mal
Also an diesen Orten in dieser Region gilt wegen Corona ein Feuerwerksverbot
Offenbach
Also Haftbefehl darf nicht bollern
Also
Okay es gibt ein Verkaufsverbot
Ja aber ich glaube das wird doch
Das geht doch voll nach hinten los oder?
Also wenn es ein Verkaufsverbot von Feuerwerk gibt
Die Leute bestellen sich einfach ihr Feuerwerk
Oder holen sich das aus Polen oder sonst wo
Okay
Also es gibt ein Verkaufsverbot von Feuerwerk
Die Leute bestellen sich einfach ihr Feuerwerk
Oder holen sich das aus Polen oder sonst wo
Oder bei AliExpress
Kann man bei AliExpress Feuerwerk bestellen
Ja
Man kann bei AliExpress Feuerwerk bestellen
Ne das ist gar kein Feuerwerk
Das ist gar kein Feuerwerk
Das sieht nur so aus
Okay okay gibt es nicht
Okay kann man nicht bestellen
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen
Dass viele Leute das entweder bestellen
Nach Polen fahren oder sonst wie
Das geht doch
Meistens nach hinten los sowas oder
Dann sprengen sich noch mehr Leute die Hände ab
Weil sie Crap Feuerwerk kaufen
Oder selbst bauen ja wer es kann
Naja
Ehrlich gesagt ist mir das wurscht
Ich weiß halt schon genug Leute gibt die das
Gern machen
Den gönn ich das irgendwo also soll ich das ruhig machen
Aber ich sag mich juckts, mich juckts net
Was?
Stimmt
Ja wenn die Metro darf kann sich da wahrscheinlich holen
Oder konnte sich das holen
Okay was will uns der Typ mit seinem Favorite Desktop sagen
Das Video sticht mir so ins Auge
Also Tanjim the Tech Guy
Was was will er
Wer will denn sowas haben
Ich will nicht dass mein Desktop so aussieht
Ich will dass mein Desktop so aussieht
Also jetzt mal ernsthaft chat
Wenn ihr die Auswahl habt zwischen diesem Desktop hier
Zwischen dem Desktop und dem Desktop
Was nehmt ihr
Was ist besser
Meiner ja eindeutig
Ja aber wozu das ist total un
Auch noch Powerpoint Presenter zu allen was will der Typ denn jetzt
Wer braucht sowas
Das ist doch total unergonomisch
Und warum
Powerpoint
Der hat doch nicht mal ne Taskleiste
Das ist total unergonomisch
Jetzt fehlt bloß noch das er auf den Kaktus klicken kann
Das passiert irgendwas
Ach du große Kacke
Wer braucht denn sowas
Nein
Wer will denn sowas haben
Ich will bloß heute
Oblikatorchen League of Legends Link
Oder sowas auf dem Desktop
Nein
Alter
Warum sollte man sich seinen Rechner so verstellen
Und dann irgendwelche komischen
Dinger aus
Frag mich nicht wo runterladen
Omni Momo Info
Was auch immer
Warum sollte ich sowas installieren
Nein
Dann noch irgendwelche Seams von Google Drive
Also wenn du danach 20 Kilo gehast
Musst du dich ja nicht wundern
Nein
Was Schwachsinn Alter
Was ein Schwachsinn warum hat er so viele gute
Bewertungen
Nein
Geh weg
Kurz Soundtrack
Excellent
Ich glaube Videospiele
Musik darf man auch spielen
Musik
Kacke
Excellent
Musik
Das kann man übrigens auch super in der loop laufen lassen
Das ist ja das soundtrack der das game über quasi zu 90 prozent in der loo im loop läuft
Das ist ein perlskript ja
Die
So hört sich übrigens acht pitt musik an die mit modernen tools erstellt wurde und eigentlich nicht acht pitt ist
Deutlich besser als auf dem ns oder so
So
So was gucken wir uns als nächstes an
Wie apple dich manipuliert apple muss mich gar nicht manipulieren die apple fanboys bringen apple schon genug geld
Zumal sich die fanboys auch gar nicht mehr die du musst die fanboys auch gar nicht mehr
Aber das schon mal geguckt du musst die fanboys auch gar nicht mehr weiter manipulieren
Die sind selbst so sehr schon darin gefangen in dieser denkweise
Dass die egal wie scheiß sich die firma verhält es immer noch weiter loben weil sonst müssten sie sich eingestehen dass sie was falsches fanboy
haben die letzten jahre
On
Dann gucken wir uns mal wie uns apple manipuliert
Die manipuliert uns apple
So ist es leider wir fast allen fanboys. Ja ist so egal ob ein video amd
Android, iOS, Apple, was auch immer, also macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Xbox, Playstation.
Man hat das ja damals immer gesehen, wenn es um 360 oder PS3 ging.
Wie krass da beide Seiten gefanboyt haben, eigentlich total unnötig.
Letztendlich macht ein sinnloses Fanboyen nur blind dafür, wenn die Firma irgendeine Scheiße baut und man es trotzdem supportet.
Eigentlich Fanboyen richtig doof.
Aber bei Handys redet man nur von Apple-Fanboys.
Nö, es gibt genug Android-Fanboys.
Aber wir wissen ja, dass das einzig wahre ePC ist.
Bei allem.
PCMR, Leute.
24 FPS reichen.
Ja, mit zwei Augen bist du schon bei 48.
Okay, exellent. Also gucken wir uns mal an, wie uns Apple verarscht.
2016 hat das bestmögliche iPhone 1119 Euro gekostet.
2020 1558 Euro und 65 Cent.
Das ist ein fast 40%ige...
Ja, und wisst ihr was das Geile ist?
Die Apple-Fanboys sagen jetzt, ja, das ist doch gar nicht so schlimm, weil du musst dir das ja nicht kaufen.
Und du kannst dir ja auch einfach ein altes, schlechteres kaufen.
Das ist ja überhaupt kein Problem.
Das heißt, lass Apple das doch machen.
Oder es gibt die anderen Fanboys, die sagen, ja, die haben ja auch das iPhone total krass verbessert.
Da kann man schon mal 500 Euro mehr für ausgeben.
Man kann sich das immer irgendwie zurechtlegen.
Deswegen ganz ehrlich, meiner Ansicht nach, ich weiß, ich hab selbst den Apple, was hab ich denn für, 1XR oder so.
Ich glaube, ich hab einen XR.
Meiner Meinung nach, das beste iPhone ist das aktuelle iPhone SE.
Das ist preislich das, was du früher für ein Top-Smartphone bezahlt hast und ist vollkommen ausreichend.
Ja klar, ja klar. Die anderen Hersteller machen da mit.
Android-Handys sind auch übertrieben viel teurer, also zumindest die High-End-Modelle mit 75 Kameras.
Viel, viel Geld, aber das Geschäft boomt und verändert.
Die Firma ist das wertvollste Unternehmen der Welt und eines der profitabelsten.
Warum geben die Leute Apple so gerne so viel Geld?
Weil sie Apple-Fanboys sind.
Okay, das hat viele Gründe, aber wir fokussieren uns heute auf eine ganz bestimmte Strategie.
Ich meine, das neue SE, nicht das 2016er SE.
Oder auch, wie man wahnsinnig hohe Preise irgendwie logisch wirken lässt.
Das ist kein Ding.
Also, hohe Preise logisch wirken lassen ist das einfachste von der Welt.
Du musst einfach, wow.
What the fuck, falsche Emote geklickt gerade.
Oh, oh my god.
Hohe Preise logisch wirken lassen ist das einfachste von der Welt.
Du musst einfach nur einen Vergleich schaffen, der den hohen Preis nicht mehr so hoch erscheinen lässt.
Zum Beispiel, du bietest ein Game an mit einem Monatsabo von 10 Euro.
Wo es im Endeffekt außer ein bisschen Ingame-Währung nichts für gibt.
So, und jetzt bietest du die Ingame-Währung aber auch zum Kaufen zusätzlich an.
Also mal angenommen, du kannst dir die Ingame-Währung kaufen für irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 10 Goldstücke für 10 Euro.
Oder du kannst ein Monatsabo abschließen für 9 Euro und du bekommst 15 Goldstücke.
So, dann sagen die Leute dann, hoh, Poggers, wer ist denn so dumm und kauft sich das normale?
Ich kauf mir das Monatsabo.
So, ganz einfach.
Und schon denken die Leute, sie haben wahnsinnig geile Schnäppchen gemacht.
Dabei wurden sie übelst, übelst hardcore jebaited vom Hersteller.
Ja, so, gucken wir mal weiter.
Und um nicht zu sagen, genau.
Ja, Bitconnect hat es auf eine andere Art und Weise probiert.
Bitconnect hat die Taktik gemacht, so, so, morgen gibt es nichts mehr.
So, ihr müsst jetzt, jetzt alle mitmachen und alle sind schon dabei.
Wie, ihr seid noch nicht dabei?
Ihr müsst jetzt auch dabei sein.
Bitconnect, yeah.
Und dann, oh, wir machen dicht.
Sagen wir, wir wollen ein neues Handy kaufen von Apple.
Um überhaupt zu dieser Entscheidung zu gelangen, haben wir schon einen weiten Weg zurückgelegt.
So elegant, so schön, die Werbung war so toll.
Ah, yes.
Ich hab da ein paar Schwörter drauf und die werden nicht so schnell langsam.
Und damn, sind die gut.
Das stimmt nicht.
Ich verwende ja immer noch ein iPhone, also hab ich noch als zweites ein iPhone 6.
Alter, ist das mittlerweile unbenutzbar.
Okay, dann investieren wir halt mal.
Jetzt stehen wir vor einer wichtigen Abwägung.
Wir geben Geld aus.
Aber wie viel?
Und hier hilft uns Apple, wie kaum ein anderes Unternehmen,
zu der einzig richtigen Entscheidung zu kommen.
Ganz viel.
Das ist das Ziel von Upselling.
Dass ein Kunde bei einem jeweiligen Kauf möglichst viel Geld ausgibt.
Ein Autohändler macht das wahrscheinlich recht aggressiv.
Oh ja, das Leder ist wirklich bequem.
Das kann ich nur empfehlen, das lohnt sich und so weiter.
Er will den finalen Kaufpreis des Autos in die Höhe treiben.
Klassischerweise durch eine luxuriöse...
Ich glaub, mein Autoradio ist mehr wert als mein Auto.
Das liegt aber auch daran, weil mein Auto ein olles Kackding ist.
Und der Radio halt ein süßlich gekaufte Shop.
Na ja, natürlich teures.
Beginnt es.
Wir könnten uns das iPhone SE holen.
Für 466,90 Euro.
Ja, beste.
Ohne Scheiß, meiner Meinung nach das beste iPhone,
was man sich kaufen kann aktuell.
Das neue iPhone SE.
Vor allem, es ist auch in einer sinnvollen Größe.
Für ein Smartphone.
Es ist nice.
Ich gebe es zu.
Es ist schon cool, wenn man ein bisschen größeres Handy hat.
Aber von der Größe und für die Hosentasche
muss ich persönlich sagen, ist die Größe das beste.
Und auch preisleistungsmäßig.
Kannste echt nichts sagen.
Die Kamera ist eigentlich relativ gut.
Also, wenn du jetzt nicht gerade künstlerisch da exquisite
ausgefallene Bilder machen willst, reicht das voll und ganz.
Wenn wir schon Geld für ein gutes Handy ausgeben,
dann ist das vielleicht auch noch gut.
Wobei, da nur etwas über 100 Euro drauf
und wir sind schon beim Zwölfer.
Das ist im Prinzip das Gleiche wie mit der Ingame-Werbung,
was ich vorhin gesagt habe.
Noch viel besserer Kamera und auch 5G und so.
Das Pro ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel.
Wobei, die Kamera ist echt so sick.
Und die halten auch ewig.
Nein, nein, nein.
Man muss auch nicht übertreiben.
Mini, das ist schon ziemlich klein, oder?
Wir schauen ja schon viele Videos auf dem Handy und so.
Und 36,51 Euro pro Monat.
5,4 Zoll Display ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Auch nicht so viel.
Alter, das ist huge.
36 Euro im Monat.
Für wie lange?
Für die nächsten 100 Jahre.
100 Jahre? Nee, für die nächsten, frag mich nicht.
2 Jahre oder so?
Oh, das Blau ist schön.
Wie viel Speicher brauchen wir denn?
64. Immer.
Ich nehme immer das kleinste.
Ich glaube, ich bin absolut nicht der richtige Typ,
der für diese Art von Marketing empfänglich ist.
60 GB ist vielleicht etwas wenig.
256 GB ist vielleicht ein bisschen unnötig.
Aber 180...
Ohne Scheiß, ich nehme fast immer das kleinste.
Weil ich höre darauf kaum Musik,
die auf dem Handy gespeichert ist.
Und 64 GB Apps reicht komplett aus.
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Wo sieht man denn,
wie viel Speicherplatz das Handy aktuell hat?
Sieht man bestimmt irgendwo in den Settings.
Nein, ich will jetzt kein Software-Update machen.
Alter, geh mir nicht auf den Sack.
Ich habe 64 GB.
Guck mal, ich habe 64 GB Speicher auf dem XR.
Und davon habe ich 42 available.
Du brauchst nichts.
28 wären doch ganz nett.
Dann ist man auch immer noch bei unter 40 Euro im Monat.
iPhone zum Tauschen haben wir leider nicht.
Ach ja, für das alte iPhone kriege ich, glaube ich, 30 Euro.
25 Euro und 5 Cent.
Zum Glück können wir einen Kredit aufnehmen,
der den tatsächlichen Preis zusätzlich verschleiert.
Die Frage ist, bei solchen geilen Krediten ist immer,
wo man genau gucken muss,
ist es nach diesen 24 Monaten wirklich vorbei?
Weil es gibt ja auch Kredite,
da bezahlst du kein Zinsen in dem Sinn,
sondern du hast dann am Ende noch 200 Euro Rest,
die du noch zusätzlich bezahlen musst.
Was halt auch fragwürdig ist,
wenn man schon zwei Jahre bezahlt,
dass man am Ende noch mal 200 Euro drauflegen muss.
...häppchen einteilt. Was ist hier passiert?
Natürlich ist unser Beispiel überspitzt.
Aber so oder so ähnlich funktioniert Upselling tatsächlich.
Man kreiert mentale Stufen im Kaufprozess
und schafft so viele kleine Vergleichsmomente.
Die Vergleiche erscheinen alle für sich genommen rational.
Klar will ich lieber eine etwas bessere Kamera.
Natürlich will ich das neueste Modell.
Weißt ihr, warum ich das iPhone SE nehmen würde,
wenn ich mir eins kaufen müsste?
Ich musste mir das XR glücklicherweise nicht kaufen.
Weil ich ganz ehrlich der Meinung bin,
dass ich habe jetzt den direkten Vergleich
zwischen dem iPhone 6 und dem iPhone XR.
Ich finde das XR von der Größe viel angenehmer
als den fetten XR-Klumpen in der Hosentasche.
Beim XR rutscht einem ja schon fast die Hose,
wenn du kein Gürtel drin hast.
Tomli, das ist natürlich schlecht.
Das sollte eigentlich nicht passieren.
Solange es nicht brennt...
Moment, Moment.
Spicke, was ist ein Fanny-Pack?
Was für ein Ding.
Was ist denn ein Fanny-Pack?
Fanny-Pack.
Ach, so eine Bauchtasche.
Ist das modern wieder?
Früher hat man sich darüber lustig gemacht.
Jetzt ist das wieder modern.
Eine kluge Entscheidung zu treffen, haben uns hier hingebracht.
Das Ganze wird noch von Apples klugem Webdesign unterstützt.
Nichts ist zu aufdringlich.
Der Prozess wirkt vor allem benutzerfreundlich.
So oder so, für Apple ist Upselling eine Goldgrube.
Schauen wir uns dafür insbesondere mal den Speicher an.
Beim iPhone 12 kann man für 165 Euro und 75 Cent...
Ach, über die Schulter trägt man das jetzt.
Aha.
Nicht viel. Guckt euch mal SSD-Preise an.
Der Speicherpreis lag im August bei ca. 6 Cent.
In unserem Fall verkauft Apple jeden Gigabyte für 86 Cent.
Also Preise für Speicher ist der Witz.
Kein Wunder, dass da keine MicroSD-Slots drin sind.
Der Apple glaub ich noch nie.
Genau damit wird die Gewinnspanne von einem Market Analyst
bei anderen iPhone-Modellen auf knapp 70 Prozent geschätzt.
Er nennt den Speicher schon damals absolut das profitabelste iPhone-Feature.
Als Kunde mögen die 166 Euro in dem Moment vielleicht fast logisch wirken.
Sind ja ganz schön viele Gigabyte.
Aber für Apple wird es basierend auf den Bloomberg-Zahlen 116 Euro Gewinn.
Nandpreise sind in letzter Zeit außerdem ordentlich gefallen.
Also ist es vielleicht sogar noch viel mehr.
All das sind natürlich nur grobe Schätzungen und Spekulation.
Wie viel Apple am Ende genau woran verdient, ist schwer abzuschätzen.
Der Speicher von iPhones ist jedenfalls nicht
mit einer günstigen MicroSD-Karte erweiterbar.
Warum nur?
Das kann technische Gründe haben.
Ach so, wir haben unser iPhone ja noch gar nicht zu Ende gekauft.
Zu guter Letzt können wir noch eine Versicherung abschließen.
Für nur 169 Euro.
Das nennt man Cross-Selling.
Hier will man kein Upgrade, sondern ein zusätzliches Produkt
oder einen Service verkaufen.
Ein bekanntes Beispiel wäre, hätten Sie gerne Pommes zu dem Burger?
Und na ja, wenn ich eh schon 900...
Leute, das Schlimmste ist Subway, was das angeht.
Ein Beispiel wäre...
Wer war in letzter Zeit mal bei Subway?
Bei mir ist schon eine Weile her.
Aber Subway ist das Schlimmste, was das in der Richtung angeht.
Wenn du da was bestellst und keine Ahnung hast,
da kommt extra Belag, extra Käse, extra Sesamzeug drauf,
extra hier, willst du da noch extra sowas haben,
da kommst du von einem 5-Euro-Sub,
kommst du irgendwie auf einen 15-Euro-Sub
und hast nicht wirklich mehr bekommen.
Subway ist der Meister des Extra-Kaufens.
Aber es lohnt sich noch nicht mal.
Subway lohnt sich eh nicht.
Das Einzige, was man bei Subway essen kann, ist Sub des Tages.
Eventuell gepaart mit Menü,
weil es früher nur 2,50 Euro mehr gekostet hat.
Dafür gab es dann All You Can Drink und Cookie, das ist okay.
Dann hast du dann 7,50 Euro bezahlt für ein Menü, vollkommen in Ordnung.
Mittlerweile ist es wahrscheinlich viel, viel teurer.
Was auch noch geht, ist, wenn du die Subway-Gutscheine hast.
Aber normal zum Subway gehen,
dann hast du ein Subway-Sandwich mit dem normalen Preis.
Und das ist der Witz,
da bezahlst du 40 Euro für einen Sandwich.
Hätten Sie gerne Pommes zu dem Burger?
Und na ja, wenn ich eh schon 925 Euro ausgebe,
will ich vielleicht auch,
dass ich im Falle eines Unglückes bestmöglich abgesichert bin.
Apples Website ist ein Paradebeispiel für Upselling online.
Viele mentale Stufen im Kaufprozess,
die wiederum viele kleine Vergleichsmomente erzeugen.
Der Kunde soll sich in diesen Vergleichen verlieren,
die in kleinen Schritten immer wieder Aussicht auf etwas Besseres bieten.
Apple ist aber natürlich bei weitem nicht das einzige Unternehmen,
das Upselling oder Cross-Selling betreibt.
Man nehme zum Beispiel die Produktvorschläge auf Amazon
oder aber auch die recht neuen Bestellterminals bei McDonald's.
Da sieht man, dass ich schon lange nicht mehr bei McDonald's war,
weil hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Vielleicht hilft es manchmal, etwas mehr über Preise zu reflektieren
und wie einem die Dinge präsentiert werden.
Es sind vielleicht nur 100 Euro extra, wenn man eh schon 800 ausgibt.
Aber für was bezahlt man da? Lohnt sich das wirklich?
Bezahlst du für die Apple-Aktie, dass sie weiter steigt?
Hey, hoffentlich hat euch dieses Video gefallen.
Ja, du sorgst dafür, dass der Apple-Aktien-Stonks-Kurs raufgeht.
Nicht mal liked, ich kann gar nicht liken, ich bin hier eingeloggt.
Am besten ist eh erst mal gucken, was der ganze Kram bei AliExpress kostet.
Gut, bei einem iPhone geht das jetzt nicht,
aber bei vielen anderen Sachen geht das.
Gerade, wenn man Technik-Kram braucht,
der letztendlich eh aus China kommt.
Und ob man sich jetzt China aus Deutschland importiertes China kauft
oder direkt in China, ist fast noch besser.
Natürlich bei Sachen, die exklusiv sind, wie bei Apple
oder auch irgendeiner Nvidia-Grafika, dann geht das nicht,
aber bei Elektronik-Kram immer China gucken.
Zumal es ja auch gar keinen Unterschied macht,
ob jeder das in China bestellt, die das dann zu euch fahren
oder ob das jemand anderes bestellt, hierher fahren,
und ihr kauft es dann da.
Würdest du dir auch 1000 Euro Grafikkarten über AliExpress holen?
Nee.
Da wirst du wahrscheinlich gescampt.
Wo ist der Unterschied von AliExpress zu Wish?
Wish ist das AliExpress für Kacknoobs.
Wish ist im Prinzip AliExpress, nur dass noch Wish dazwischen ist.
Weil Wish verkauft den Kram ja gar nicht selbst.
Wish stellt einen Plattformen bereit,
wo Leute Sachen verkaufen können, die sie gar nicht haben,
und dann einfach eure Daten an den China-Hersteller weitergebt,
den ihr auch direkt kaufen könntet,
bei dem ihr auch direkt kaufen könntet,
besonders bei AliExpress oder Banggood,
und die schicken es dann direkt aus China zu euch
oder von irgendeinem EU-Warenlager zu euch.
Also im Prinzip ist Wish bestellen,
AliExpress bestellen nur für Kacknoobs und mit Scam-Garantie.
Zoll musst du dir keine Gedanken machen.
Also aus China sind die ziemlich gut drin,
die Zollsachen korrekt zu deklarieren.
Oder zumindest sie so zu deklarieren, dass sie nicht beim Zoll landen.
Und wenn du ganz auf Loma sicher gehen willst,
dann gehst du zum Beispiel, wenn du hier bei Banggood irgendwas bestellst,
dann bestellst du mit EU-Priority-Line.
Und wenn du mit EU-Priority-Line bestellst,
dann hast du eh kein Problem mehr,
weil diese neuen Zollbestimmungen, die ab nächstem Jahr gelten,
die gelten nur für Sendungen, die direkt aus China
oder aus dem nicht-EU-Ausland an dich geschickt werden.
Und was die mit EU-Priority-Line machen, ist ganz einfach.
Das ist eigentlich Big Brain Stonks Logik,
also Massive Brain, was die Chinesen da machen.
Das bedeutet, wenn du EU-Priority-Line bestellst,
dann entweder schicken die das direkt aus der EU los,
weil die einen Warenlager in der EU haben,
oder zum Beispiel Niederlande mit PostNL und sowas in AliExpress,
oder aber zum Beispiel schicken sie es erst nach Spanien.
Und in Spanien wird es dann quasi an dich geschickt.
Das heißt, für dich ist es eine Sendung aus der EU in die EU,
und du musst kein Zoll bezahlen.
Ja.
Zollbeamte hassen diesen Trick.
Genau.
Aber das ist auch so, euch kann da eh nichts passieren,
wenn schon ist der Hersteller dran, wenn er Scheiße baut,
aber das kann euch ja auch egal sein.
Und ja, ich hatte auch viel mehr Probleme aus den USA,
weil es die Hersteller aus den USA nicht hinbekommen,
die Sachen richtig zu verdingsen, zu deklarieren.
Ja, ich kenne das gerne. Beste. Huge.
Ich mag die Musik halt auch.
Das bieten die an, genau.
Und nachdem jetzt neue Zollregelungen ab Anfang 2021 in Kraft sind,
werden immer mehr China-Hersteller gar nicht mehr das Normale anbieten,
sondern gleich direkt EU-Priority Line, EU-Prior...
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was der Unterschiede dazwischen ist.
Das Zeug für den Fernseher war halt ultra teuer,
weil ich aus den USA bestellt habe und dies wieder nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt habe.
Ja, da wo ich fast das Doppelte bezahlt habe nach Zoll und FAT
und Mehrwertsteuer und Zollgebühren und haste nicht gesehen Versand,
als das, was es ursprünglich in USD gekostet hat.
Ja. Echt so.
Keck weh.
Max, was hast du eigentlich für dein Ducky-Keyboard bezahlt?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Das habe ich jetzt schon zwei Jahre oder so.
Was kostet denn sowas?
Ja, ich denke mal, dass ich auch so in dem Dreh,
dass ich sowas in dem Dreh bezahlt habe.
Wahrscheinlich so 100, 115 Euro oder so.
Oh, das ist ja günstig.
Das ist ja ist ja ein Schnapper. Warum ist das so günstig?
Warum kostet das nur eine Million?
Erhalten Sie sechs Euro Rabatt. Das macht jetzt die Sache auch nicht mehr fett.
Moment, ist das überhaupt Euro oder waren das waren das irgendwelche Rubel oder?
Das ist eine China-Seite.
Das ist einfach mal eine China-Seite.
Alles klar.
Klingt äußerst vertrauenserweckend. Was übrigens auch gut ist, dass es reduziert ist.
Also ich bin ja froh, dass es von 1,2 Millionen auf nur ungefähr knapp eine Million reduziert ist.
In den Warenkorb, easy.
Ah, Express.
Stimmt nicht mal SSL, null.
Ist das ein Fake Shop? Was kosten da andere Sachen?
Okay, andere Sachen heißen halbwegs normal, heiße Artikel.
Ja, Kaluwanet, DLC Map, Black Ops 1.
Ein wahrer Schnapper.
Mal ein Screenshot machen.
Okay, sehr schön.
Jetzt gerade mal kurz was gucken.
Hat Windows irgendwie, irgendwie Whois oder sowas?
Haben die sowas?
Ja, mal eine Lidungskiste an.
Kurz gucken, auf wen das registriert ist, aber wahrscheinlich...
Ach nee, für DE-Einträge gibt es ja gar nichts mehr, ne?
DE-Einträge sind ja, kannst ja nicht mehr Whoissen.
Ost.
Ah, mal kurz mal eine Lidung machen.
Ach, jetzt ist es doch, Moment.
Es ist HTTPS, aber not secure, warum nicht?
Moment, warum ist es not secure?
Ach so, weil eingebundener Content nicht SSL ist.
Ah ja, okay, okay.
Los.
Also, Moment, hier.
Also, zeigt mal, ja.
Techobuy.
Jaja.
Ja, gibt es nicht mehr. Ah, Cloudflare auch noch.
Alles klar, exzellent, exzellent.
Mixed Content, ja, wahrscheinlich.
Die Musik ist nice.
So, Leute, wisst ihr was?
Ich muss schon die ganze Zeit mal aufs Klo.
Und ich kriege Hunger.
Wir machen jetzt Schluss mit aufwachen Stream.
Ich hoffe, ihr seid alle wach.
Vielleicht spielen wir nachher noch eine Runde Battlefield 3.
Aber zumindest spätestens morgen, wenn Venice Unleashed rauskommt
und es zu sinnvollen EU-Zeiten rauskommt,
dann spielen wir Battlefield 3.
Kurz gucken, ob es da irgendwas Neues gibt.
Interessiert nicht so wirklich viele Leute, ne?
Timerscom.
Discord.
Exzellent.
Ach so, ich habe es hier noch nicht im Browser auf gehabt, verstehe.
Also, Leute, alles klar.
Schön, dass so viele wieder dabei waren.
Entweder sehen wir uns heute Mittag noch mal
mit ein paar Runden Battlefield 3.
Oder morgen, falls Venice Unleashed
zu ordentlichen EU-Zeiten rauskommt.
Was ist das? Das ist ein Modding-Pack für Battlefield 3,
die aber angeblich auch Custom-Server direkt zu Release haben.
Mit neuem Content. Mal gucken.
Heute Mittag, ja.
Ja, Fatal, wenn du wieder mit Battlefield 3 spielen willst, sag Bescheid, ja.
Also, wir sehen uns, Leute. Bis dann. See you.